- Can you be cancelled for your dreams?
(Garnt laughs)
Would you rather utter
a racist word asleep,
or shit yourself?
- I'd rather shit myself.
I will poop myself on stream for $100,000.
- A new Trash Taste
shitting special, let's go.
(all laughing)
(relaxed music)
- What's up Tomato Town,
welcome back to another episode
of "Trash Taste Podcast" .
- We're referring to, there's
no one in Tomato Town, Joe.
- Ah, shit.
- They're wiped out.
- Right.
- They're talking to nobody,
Joe. You're talking to nobody.
- It's gonna be real awkward
if this meme is dead.
(all laughing)
By the time this comes out.
- No, we'll bring it back.
- Knowing how fast memes fucking recycle,
it's pretty obvious.
- I will be singing Chug Jug
until the end of the year.
I swear to god.
- I doubt that. I put money on it.
- By this time next month, everyone
will be like 'what is a chug jug?'
Anyway, I'm your host for this week, Joey,
with the boys Connor and Garnt.
And we will not be talking
about Fortnite memes today.
- I mean, you know me.
I'm a pro Fortnite gamer.
- Honestly, this is like,
literally the meme of
like, you know the three children sitting
on the couch, like.
(all laughing)
'What's your favourite Fortnite meme?'
- What's the title of that
video again? It's like.
- You are nearly 40 years old,
what is your favourite Fortnite meme?
- What's the title of that video again?
What is it?
- I've forgotten what it is.
- Its like, its something
about Fortnite right?
- Yeah.
- Of course.
- I don't remember.
- I mean, you know when you see, like,
a meme picture and you just have no idea
what the original context
of that picture is?
- Yeah.
- Like, there's so many
pictures that I recognise
that I have no idea.
- One that I wanna know is like,
what's the context of that picture
of like, you know the
dude sitting next to like,
the three pictures of like,
the people having a podcast?
- I don't know.
- I wanna know the
context of that, because
we see that all the time on our subreddit.
But, anyway.
- We're not gonna be
talking about that. Yeah.
- Yeah
- Yeah, we're not gonna
be talking about that.
- [Connor] Not gonna
- We're gonna be talking, today,
about YouTube stuff? I guess.
- Twitter stuff? I don't know.
- Twitter stuff? Just internet stuff.
- Well I think there's been a few recent
interesting things that
have happened, but.
- As recording.
- Yeah, we're recording not any more,
because we're having a
bit of a two week break
of recording, so it's gonna be,
- Yeah.
- Like, six weeks from
when we talk about it.
(all laughing)
- This'll be all news by the
time you guys are seeing it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But, yeah, so, as of us recording this,
I think, was it two days ago?
- Yeah.
- YouTube, the official
Twitter account on YouTube
announced an interesting update?
- [Garnt] They are testing
to see whether they should
get, just, get rid of, well testing?
Which, when YouTube
starts to test something,
90% of the time it goes through.
- Yeah.
- So, they are testing to see
if it's worth getting
rid of dislike button.
Wait, not getting rid of
it, but getting rid of,
- Getting rid of how many dislikes
are publicly seen on video.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Essentially.
- Yeah. I hope they, its
gonna be real awkward
if they revert it by
the time this comes out.
- I mean I just hope.
- I mean, even if they revert it,
I do want them to.
I will say on the record now that I think
its a fucking stupid idea.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- So, just in recent memory, what's,
the only things that I can recall
that YouTube backpedaled on,
was the verification thing, where,
- Verification thing?
- Yeah, like, a year and a half ago,
or two years ago, they were like,
'Umm, no one's verified anymore.'
- Oh yeah, that's right!
- 'and only select
channels can be verified.'
- Oh I think it's only
music channels, right?
- People with like, 10 million subscribers
weren't like, eligible or something.
And it was like, what, who the fuck
can be verified then?
(Joey laughing)
There was that, and then there was
the YouTube Heroes,
which was the end of end as well.
- Oh my god.
- Oh my fucking god,
I've completely forgotten
about YouTube Heroes.
- That wasn't like, last year? Was it?
- No, no, that was like, four years ago.
- What was YouTube Heroes, again?
- It was basically where
they were gonna, like,
let people be, like, moderators, in a way?
- Oh yeah. That was it.
- I think it was their answer to like,
Twitch Mods.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Also just calling it 'Heroes' is like,
(Garnt laughing)
there are heroes.
- I mean, as the heroes of anime.
(all laughing)
Yeah, but. There's just
been, I don't know.
I feel, especially, with like, these.
We were talking about it
before this podcast started.
But, I feel that, when
YouTube suggests a change,
or an implementation to the system,
its not so much a suggestion.
Its more like, 'hey so,
no one asked for this,
and we're gonna tell you right
before it starts happening,
but this is what's happening.
If you disagree with it, LOL sorry.'
- Yeah they also tested,
one time, as well, like,
just getting rid of people's thumbnails,
like that was a thing, remember that?
(Garnt laughing)
- No?
- Oh no, no, it was like, the
animated thumbnails, right?
- Right.
- It was like, where the previews,
I mean, nowadays on
YouTube I think its like,
if you hover over a video thumbnail,
then it plays, like, a preview?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Of the video?
But before, yeah, I remember this.
They were gonna get rid
of the idea of thumbnails,
and just replace it with
the previews of thumbnails.
- I don't know if that was the intention,
- Right.
- I could be wrong, but I just remember
there was a period where I would just,
log on YouTube, and,
- Everything was moving?
- No, everything was moving,
or there was just no
thumbnails for anything.
(Garnt laughing)
and then I found out later it was because
of this YouTube test they were doing,
on like 0.1%.
- It just looked like, its just like a,
you know those newspapers
from Harry Potter.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Where like, everything is just moving.
- Its just annoying because
every, it seems like, to me,
as a content creator,
every time YouTube takes one step forward,
they just take two steps back.
Like what was really sus about
that Twitter post for me,
was they were just like,
'guys, we hear you. We
hear the creator feedback.
We know you asked for this.'
(Joey laughing)
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah!]
- We are removing the dislike button.
And then every creator
comes up and was like,
'Yo. Did you guys ask for this?
Because I didn't ask for this.'
- Whose feedback is this?
(all laughing)
- Because anyone who's making
any content that is like,
reasonable, anyone who's like,
literally trying to make good stuff,
probably isn't afraid
of the dislike button.
- Yeah.
- Because, you know, personally, you know,
I mean, might change by this point,
I've never had a video
that has ever been, like,
you know, less than 90%.
Yeah, less than 90% likes.
- Yeah, I mean, I feel like,
if it is less than 90% likes,
- You fucked up.
- Like, either you fucked up,
or it got recommended to
an audience way outside
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
of your usual audience. Which
is, which is what I noticed.
But yeah, I feel like the
dislike button and like,
the dislike bar, at least,
I think its a really useful resource.
- Yeah, and I saw, 'cause I retweeted it
with the Fallout 'Everyone
disliked this' picture.
But I was reading through
the replies for that tweet,
and there were a lot of really, like,
interesting points being
made, being like, you know.
One of the biggest points I saw
from a lot of big creators was that
'well, if we get rid of the dislike bar,
then how are people going to judge whether
the video is like, a scam, or, you know,
something is like, just, you know.
You don't wanna waste your
time on a 10 minute video.
- [Garnt] Yeah. I think,
- If it's a scam.
- I think the first thing
that came to mind was,
for me, was tutorial videos.
- I was just about to say that.
- The first thing,
because there are so many
useless fucking tutorial videos.
And you know immediately
when you click on something
and the dislike bar is, its a 50-50 ratio,
you're just like, all right.
- Immediately close down.
- Immediately close down
and go to the next one.
- Like back in he day, you know maybe,
you know, maybe you wanted
a certain, you know,
you wanted some software,
that you probably should
have been paying for,
you know. I remember that, you know,
the way that you would judge
if it was a safe way to get it
was like, all right, this
video has lots of comments,
lots of likes.
- [Joey] Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- I think this is safe.
You click on another video,
its like, 'get this software for free',
and its like, 80% dislikes, you're like,
'probably not gonna download that.'
- Get it from 'this will definitely
not hack your computer .com!'
- [Connor] Yeah.
- For me, its, you know,
sometimes fucking Windows
or some software gets this random error,
and you're just, you start Googling it,
and for some reason,
for me, I've found that
YouTube tutorial videos has
been more useful than just
Googling it and going into
specific Microsoft forums.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Which is just, like,
- From like six years ago.
- Yeah!
- And you look at it and its like,
posted in 2012, no replies.
Its like, cool, thanks!
(all laughing)
- Its no replies, or you get about, like,
'try these ten million fixes,
and one of these will possibly work!
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But then like, I'm
just going on a tangent,
its fucking bullshit as well,
because sometimes they'll
have like, you know,
when you have like, a problem
that's like, very minor,
and they'll be like,
'try uninstalling your RAM
and GPU, putting it back in.'
Like, I'm not gonna fucking do that.
Like at that point, I'm giving up.
I'm throwing it in the trash.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- But like I feel that, the
way YouTube tutorials work,
is that, you know, you
search up this error code,
and put it in YouTube, and like,
there's gonna be one video
that's got a positive
like to dislike ration,
- Right.
- And 90% of the time, that's
the fix I'm looking for.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Because every other video
is just like, 50-50%s, right?
And I feel like, to me,
that's like,
legitimately the first
thing that came to mind,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- About removing dislikes.
- Its frustrating as well because I think
there have been changes that
YouTube has made that, like.
Because I think whenever
YouTube makes any change,
they get shit, like even
if its a good change?
- Oh yeah, of course, yeah.
- You know, and I think
they have made some changes
where everyone was shitting
on it when it started,
and literally a week
later, no one gives a fuck.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Right.
- Like, people, like, okay.
I understand why they did this,
and it was quite
frustrating to get used to,
but when they moved the comments, to like,
(affirmative murmuring)
the comments used to be,
when you would be on a YouTube video,
like this one right now,
you could just scroll
and the comments would be
right there at the bottom!
- [Joey] Right.
- Uh, but then they moved it,
so that you had to just drop
down at it was right there.
(affirmative murmuring)
Which, at first, I absolutely hated.
I thought, why would you do this?'
- Yeah.
- And then now, I'm like,
this makes way more sense.
- Mmm.
- Yeah.
- Now that I've gotten used to it,
its streamlined everything.
If I wanna read the comments,
I'll open it, if I wanna just, you know.
I don't wanna have to scroll through
all these fucking videos, you know.
- I mean, if we're going
you know, all the way back
to the like, OG times right, like,
I remember, there was
a massive uproar when
YouTube changed, you know,
from the five star rating.
- That was dog shit anyway.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean, I understand.
- With Netflix, as well
- Yeah.
- I mean, I understand it,
and I prefer this new YouTube.
- Oh yeah, of course, but like,
I remember back in the
day, people were like,
'no I'm so used to rating five stars,'
now YouTubers were like
'well how am I gonna end off the video?
I used to be able to say rate five stars,
but now I got to like,
ask people to like?'
- Smash the like button?
- Eurgh, smash the like button?
(fake vomiting)
- Yeah, so.
- I do think that when they
do these changes, as well,
like, they must have
some data on their end.
That says this is a good idea.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Well, yeah. Its not
completely, baseless, I'm sure.
- Right. Which is why, like,
I wish that they would be like 'listen,'
- Open about it?
- 'This is our idea,
right? We're thinking,'
- Not be like, 'listen. We hear you.'
(Joey laughing)
- Not, yeah.
- I fucking hate that.
- Don't fucking pretend like
you're doing me a solid.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Don't pretend like you give a shit
about the people who use your website.
(all laughing)
- Thanks, thanks
corporation, my best friend!
- [Joey] Wow.
- You wanna do me a solid
and reply to me when I
have a fucking problem.
(all laughing)
Don't fucking tell me that
you're removing dislikes,
like they give a.
And the only reason they're
fucking doing it anyway,
and I'm pretty sure everyone knows
they're doing it because
of this is like, you know,
a bunch of really big names
got into controversies,
- Yeah.
- And dislikes play a really pivotal part.
- [Joey] Right.
- And like, 'cause, you
know, I think, in YouTube,
we have this way where we have like,
kind of decided, that a
YouTube apology, if you will,
its success is based on like to dislike.
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah.
- Right?
- So I think that YouTube
is trying to get rid of that
where we judge a video's quality on that.
- Well, I kind of like that
because, I mean obviously,
you know, I wouldn't be saying this
if I was on the receiving end of it.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But as someone who's seen,
you know, an apology video or whatever.
- I think its awesome as a viewer.
- Its also cool, as well,
because I, a lot of the times,
use that as a gauge to figure out, like,
the general idea of what the community
thinks about this particular field.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, because sometimes, you know,
when these apology videos
come out, and I'm like,
'eh, that's a good apology',
I look at the video and there's like,
you know, 20,000 likes
to 100,000 dislikes,
I'm like, whoa, why's everyone, like.
- Yeah.
- What did I do?
- [Joey] Right.
- Am I missing something here?
- Exactly, exactly. Like, it kind of re,
I guess it like, rejustifies like, oh,
do I really, fully understand
the whole context of this video?
Because, I might think this
is a good apology video,
but 100,000 other people disagree.
So its kinda like, oh
okay well then, maybe
I should look into it more, but.
- Also there's just something cathartic
about having the dislike button there.
(affirmative murmuring)
you know, it is, it
just doesn't feel right
if you're just smashing a button,
and it just doesn't really mean anything.
(affirmative murmuring)
Its like, its like, going onto a video,
right? And just seeing
the comments turned off.
Nothing makes me more like, angry, than
(Joey laughing)
going on a video, and wanting, no.
Not even wanting to comment on it,
just wanting to see what
other people think of it.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
And just being removed
removed that privilege.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- And I just feel like, as well,
this is just gonna lead
to more shitty comments.
(affirmative murmuring)
Because if you take away one avenue,
as, you know, you know, we all saw with,
what is it? Like, Twitter, right?
Its just ratio-ing them.
That's like, the new thing.
- Did Twitter ever have a dislike button?
I don't think it did.
- No.
- No, they never had a dislike button.
- Yeah.
- No, but, they changed, oh they took, oh.
I feel like ratio-ing is
a recent thing, though.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, ratio-ing is a
recent thing, yeah, yeah.
- Why did ratio-ing start happening?
- I think its because,
- Do we wanna explain what ratio-ing is?
(all laughing)
Because I've talked to several people,
and they've not known what ratio is.
- Well, ratio-ing, oh, I
mean do you wanna explain?
- On Twitter?
- Oh yeah its basically like,
where, if a tweet is so bad,
right? You'll know its an awful tweet
when there'll be like,
more replies than likes.
- Yeah.
- That's called ratio-ing because like,
the ratio is so much higher
to comments than likes.
- Or if the reply to the original tweet
has more likes than the original tweet.
- Exactly, yeah, yeah.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Its like both, either ways, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I feel like, you know,
if there's likes on the video,
people are just gonna start
ratio-ing in the comments.
- Oh, yeah.
- Literally they're just gonna
like up the one talking shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But on YouTube you can like,
delete the comments as well.
- [Joey] Right. Exactly.
- I don't know. It just
seems like a stupid idea,
I don't know.
- [Joey] But that's the thing, right?
Its like, that's the thing, right?
And I think that's why its
such a big problem for people,
because I think a lot of
YouTubers realise that,
because creators can, and have
the space to delete comments,
if they want to, and delete like,
hateful, hurtful, negative comments.
- Which you should be able to.
- Which you should be able
to, don't get me wrong.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But, you know, you can't
get rid of a dislike. Right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And for a lot of people, if
they go onto a YouTube video,
and they realise 'oh, this
person who uploaded this video
is getting rid of negative comments'.
- [Connor] Yep.
Well then, the only other way
I can express how I feel about this video,
is to hit the dislike button.
- Yeah. And another thing is like,
the way they framed it,
like they were doing a
solid for the creator,
where the creator, they literally said
the creator can still see how
many dislikes this video has.
- [Joey] Right.
- So, it doesn't help the creator at all,
because they're the only
ones who can still see it!
- Right!
I felt the exact same way when Instagram
got rid of publicly showing
how many likes a post has,
and yet the creator
can still see how many likes the post has.
I'm just like, what's the difference?
At that point. Like, you're still putting,
this like, pressure on the
person putting it up, right?
- With Instagram, I'd actually argue
I think it was a good thing.
- I think it was a good thing.
- You think so?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think so. Because I
think Instagram was like,
highly competitively toxic.
(affirmative murmuring)
With likes.
- I guess maybe I didn't think that way
because I'm not part of that.
- I'm not into that.
- I'm not a like, if you
follow me on Instagram,
I'm sorry, that there is just like,
zero content and zero updates at all.
Its a dead account.
- Really says a lot when
out of the three of us,
I'm the most active on Instagram.
(Garnt laughing)
And yet, I post like, once a month.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I just like, don't like
the platform that much.
(affirmative murmuring)
and I think it used be like,
the likes was definitely
a thing that I didn't really like at all.
(affirmative murmuring)
Because to me, that was like,
- 'Cause it really felt like
people were just like-farming.
And just like, fucking,
it really bred this
toxic kind of environment
where people were,
it was literally like, a
clout-chasing kind of platform.
- Well, then, question,
then. Would you guys,
if Twitter, for example,
implemented the same things Instagram do,
would you be okay with it?
- I would, actually.
- Really?
- Ah, I dunno. I feel
like Twitter's different.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- I wouldn't want it on Twitter.
Wait. Before we get into that,
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- I have this like, I
don't know this is like,
a tin foil hat, a part of me just thinks
is YouTube just trying
to shift all the drama
onto like, Twitter? You can't.
Because you now right, let's
say you, you know, you can't,
you can't dislike something publicly,
let's say the comments are filtered.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
I wonder if YouTube is just being like
'go to Twitter, go and argue
on Twitter. Don't fuck around,'
- I didn't think about that, but that's,
- You know, with the dislikes gone,
what is there to do?
Other than comment, and you know,
a lot of the time, with these videos,
people are just gonna
turn off comments, right?
- Fucking great, just even more toxicity
heading towards twitter.
(Garnt laughing)
- I do wonder that, because you know,
even if you're a YouTube creative,
if all the shit's going down on Twitter,
I wonder if YouTube can be like,
- I mean like, I feel like
that's not going to happen
because there's been
such an increase on like,
commentary and drama channels now,
(affirmative murmuring)
that the conversation is still
going to stay on YouTube,
its just a lot of people, maybe,
can only publicly comment
about it on Twitter.
- Yeah also, also if anything,
it does really seem like,
at first glance, it does seem like,
everyone who is following
something on YouTube
also uses Twitter. But that
is really not the case.
Like, I very quickly found out that yes,
even though I might have a
massive following on Twitter,
compared to, like, the
people who use YouTube,
its really not a lot. Its not
even the majority of people?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like, I remember like,
there was this one time
where like, I posted
something on my Twitter,
and then I talked about it on my YouTube,
and I got a lot of people being like,
'well, I don't use Twitter.'
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But in the back of my head I was like,
oh, yeah! There are some
people who don't use Twitter.
- No I mean, I think its
gotten to the point now
where I've kind of had
this realisation where,
every platform is kind
of like, in its own,
its, most of the time,
its in its own bubble.
- [Joey] Right.
- You can be really
popular on one platform,
and then open an account
on another platform,
and just have like, zero followers.
- I mean, there's so many like,
you know, YouTubers who
have a million plus subs
on their YouTube,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But then when you go onto their Twitter,
they have, you know, less
than 50,000 followers.
- Its the content right,
like, that's kind of how it.
- But like, also like, I can't imagine
how many fucking TikTokers
I just don't know about,
just because I'm not on the platform.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- And the thing is, like, they
can open a Twitter account,
because to me, like, the
way I see Twitter now
is just like, fucking influencer Facebook.
(all laughing)
- It literally is, yeah.
- That's basically what
its like for me now,
and like, sometimes I hear
about a TikToker who has like,
fucking millions and millions
of followers on TikTok,
opens a Twitter, and its like.
You know, less followers than us.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Even though they have like,
more followers on their own platform.
- [Joey] Right.
- In YouTube terms, if they
had that many subscribers,
on like, YouTube, then they
would be massive creators.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Not all followers, slash
subscribers are created equal,
though, right? So.
- Yeah that's, that's true.
Like, it also really depends on
how much you focus and
post on that platform.
- Yeah, that's true.
- And how much you're
known by your audience
to use that platform.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah. Man. I wondered,
because I'm thinking like,
you know, as content creators,
you know, if you're somebody who, say,
does not give a fuck about
anything and you're like,
'I don't care about what
people say about me,'
I feel like the only,
really, tool that like,
an audience or a platform has to kind of,
what's the word? Police
you, or give feedback,
is like, public shaming, almost.
I feel like getting rid of
the dislike is a part of like,
you know, taking away from that.
Because I feel like, as content creations,
content creations,
creators, sorry, oh my gosh.
You know, the only real
tool other than like,
YouTube deleting your channel is like,
you know, I know it sounds bad, because
it sounds really fucking
terrifying, this public shaming.
But that's like, the only real tool,
(affirmative murmuring)
that is there to like, stop
you from doing shitty stuff.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Most of the time. For a lot of people.
Who are, questionable.
- I don't think, removing
the dislike button
is not gonna get rid of toxicity.
- No.
- [Joey] No.
- Its not. Like, its just
gonna get other people
to figure out other creative ways
to produce that toxicity, right?
- Exactly, right? All
that's gonna happen is
gonna shift into another form,
and I feel like, to me,
removing the dislike button is
just so weird, to me.
- Its just censorship.
- I don't think its censorship.
- I feel like its a form of it, right?
Because again, like, you
know, if there's, again,
like, a video where its an
apology video or something
controversial, and you
turn off the comments
and the dislikes aren't showing,
then how else are you
supposed to say anything?
- I feel like the term censorship
gets thrown around a lot nowadays,
I feel like this is pushing the definition
of what censorship is.
Well what it is, is
that its removing a way
for us to express ourselves.
- I wonder if its a similar case to when
you know, when the whole
'Kids on YouTube' thing,
- Yep.
- Where they were all doing,
like gymnastics or something,
people were commenting gross things.
(affirmative murmuring)
And then YouTube's response was
'well,
we'll just turn off all the
comments for kids' videos.'
(Garnt laughing)
And then YouTube's like, well
there's no more paedophiles
on YouTube now. They're all gone.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah. If you can't see paedophiles,
then they're not there, right?
- 'What do you mean, where are they?
There's no realization on
YouTube, there's no dislikes,
what do you mean?'
It almost feels like
that. That YouTube's like,
if you just remove the option
to show it publicly to anyone,
- Yeah.
- It doesn't exist.
- Its just the whole like, see
no evil, hear no evil, right?
- Yeah. There's fucking tons
of videos of kids doing,
probably inappropriate
things on YouTube still,
and that fucking creeps are
still watching them, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- But now its harder to
fucking find these videos
and report them! Because, you know,
how the fuck are you
supposed to when you know,
there's not like, a bunch of
creepy dudes in the comments.
- Unless you like, actively go out
and search for those videos,
but who the fuck is wasting
their time doing that, right?
- Pedophiles.
(all laughing)
- I mean like, normal people
who are trying to get rid of those, right?
- Yeah, I mean, there's so many circles
and so many like, rabbit holes that
I'm sure people can fall down in YouTube
that we are just not aware of.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, because that just
shows how big YouTube is
as a platform how like, I feel for YouTube
because when you have a platform this big,
no matter what you do,
there's going to be something
wrong with your platform.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah. 100%.
- But I feel like, what they're doing
with the dislike button is its
going in the wrong direction.
Just because, just
because a problem exists,
like, removing your ability to express it,
or removing your ability
to see that problem
doesn't get rid of the problem.
- [Joey] Right.
- It just shifts it to somewhere else.
- And, yeah, I don't know.
I really don't know
what they were thinking.
- I feel like its not even about like,
shifting it, as well.
Its not only shifting it,
but I feel, more times than not,
it also propels it? Into something like,
a lot more toxic and a lot
more just, out of control.
- I think it, I think it
would breed more toxicity
because that just means people
have to find another way.
- It just means that,
like, the people who are
shouting the toxicity now just
have to shout it even louder.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- For them to be like, oh,
I need people to see what
I have a problem with.
- Yeah. Because if, like,
part of the catharsism,
I don't know if that's a
word, of seeing a shitty video
is just knowing that you're
not the only one who agrees
that this is a shitty video.
- [Joey] Yeah, right. Exactly.
- Right? And there's,
you know, it is good,
when you see this bad
video or this bad apology,
and you know, you can see that one,
the first thing that you
see is the dislike button,
and the dislike bar. Like, my god.
It was great seeing like, YouTube Rewinds
and just seeing that
everyone collectively agreed
that it was just, a train wreck, right?
Sorry YouTube, but it was.
- I love how a lot of the
comments, as well, were like,
ah man, YouTube was just
salty that they got ratio'd.
(all laughing)
- I don't think that was
the reason, on record,
but it was funny.
- It was a good meme, it was a good meme.
- I don't think that was
the reason, on record.
(all laughing)
like this is the official
reason you're salty.
- Corporates at YouTube are like, fuck,
I can't believe people hate
our products like this.
- Susan's just like, 'I'm
never gonna forgive them,
I cannot believe it'.
(all laughing)
'After all these years,'
she's just been planning this for years
(Joey laughing)
waiting for like, the right
person to be cancelled
to be like, okay, now's the time.
- Now we have an excuse!
Now we have an excuse to implement this.
- I wonder if they were like,
there was this YouTube meeting,
and they were like,
'guys, everyone's hating on
cancel culture right now?
Let's be the ones to end cancel culture.
Let's remove the dislike
button.' And they're like
'oh my god you're a genius! They're gonna,
oh YouTube is gonna love this!'
- Who would have thought it was that easy?
- They can't be cancelled
anymore, there's no dislikes!
Why is everyone hating
this?! What is happening?
Oh, I thought we were doing a good thing!
- I thought you guys hated cancel culture!
- We're removing negativity! What?
(all laughing)
That's what it feels like.
- Yeah, it really is, yeah.
- Just 'cause like, before
this, I would say that,
actually, I think YouTube was
in a pretty healthy stage.
- Yeah, Twitter was fucked,
but YouTube was good.
- [Joey] Yeah, YouTube was good.
- Twitter was like, toxic
and obviously felt a bit vile sometimes,
but YouTube just felt like,
just a dislike and that was it.
- It was just, it was a nice balance.
- A nice little finger, like fuck you.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Or like, fuck you, okay,
I'll get on with my day now.
You know?
- Yeah.
- And like, I think they have done
a lot of positive changes,
I do like the changes they
did to the copyright system.
Its not perfect, but its
better than it was before.
I like the fact that you have to like,
specifically put a timestamp
of what part of your
video's been copyrighted
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And as a creator, you can
still remove that, you know,
part that's been copyright striked,
and have no effect on your
channel. I think that's like,
the best balance that
we could have hoped for.
- And when you appeal
for it, it like, goes,
the money you make from that video
now goes into this limbo state where
it doesn't go to the creator,
and it doesn't go to the
supposed copyright holder.
- Yeah, that was a good change!
- Which was fucking fanta, its like,
we've been wanting that for years now,
and YouTube was like,
we've heard your feedback.
- To be fair, that probably
should have happened
in the beginning.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It should have, like.
- I mean it should have
happened in the beginning,
but what I'm saying is,
- They eventually did it.
- Yeah, they eventually did it,
and it felt like this change,
the changes they're making
now, is just unnecessary,
because nobody asked for
this, and I think, right now,
before this, as a content
creator, I was pretty happy
with YouTube as a platform, you know?
(affirmative murmuring)
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You knew what, you knew
what you could get away with,
you knew what you couldn't get away with.
You know, if, I feel like
right now, if a video,
if one of your videos gets
demonetised, aside from
Trash Taste videos, because,
- Yeah, I don't know why
half of the videos that got
demonetised got demonetised, because
- Yeah, yeah. Well like, most of the time,
if I upload something and
its a 10 to 15 minute,
I know which videos are more
high-risk to get demonetised.
- [Joey] Yeah. Of course.
- And I know, most of the
time, its kind of on me
for making that video subject.
(affirmative murmuring)
and then, you have Trash
Taste, where, for some reason,
some of our podcast episodes
just get demonetised,
and we hit, and its just like,
(Joey laughing)
we hit the appeal button, and
I guarantee, the person who's
like, reviewing the content
did not watch the entire 2 hours.
- They're like 'ah fuck, its 2 hours long,
Jim, you gonna watch the whole thing? No?
Fuck it, we'll just
leave you yellow then.'
(all laughing)
What's weird about the Trash
Taste episodes is that,
I think, on record, we have about like,
five or six of the episodes
now that are still demonetised,
but its five or six of the episodes
that shouldn't have been demonetised.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- We look at it, we look
back at them and we're like,
I don't know what part of
this video flagged what,
but, we have like, a bunch
of other videos and episodes,
where its like, these are the ones,
if anything, that should
have been demonetised.
- [Connor] Yeah, true yeah, yeah.
- But they're not for some reason?
- Like the convenience
episode, that got demonetised,
- Yeah, the combini
episode got demonetised,
and yet the hentai episode
is still monetised.
- Hey, dude, dude.
(Garnt shushing)
- Don't tell them that.
(Garnt laughing)
- Ah sorry, the fancy font episode.
One is still monetised, yeah.
- The Greek, the Greek letter,
(all fake laughing)
- Anyway,
(all sighing)
I don't know, the one time, like, one day
I think to myself 'okay, I've figured out,
what exactly YouTube does not like,
about whatever video it is that
flags the demonetisation
system,' and then the next day,
I'm like, 'nevermind, I
don't know what you want.'
- Because another thing I've
noticed about YouTube recently,
is, in a positive light,
when did YouTube comments get really good?
(Joey laughing)
Is that just me?
- What do you mean?
- What do you mean, good?
- The comments sections right now, like,
you click on a random meme video,
and the comments are always golden, and,
it didn't used to be that way because
it used to be this one overused joke
in every comment section, but,
- 'No one, comma.'
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like the no one joke.
- They're all fucking copypastas.
- Yeah, yeah. But nah, but nah,
I don't know if its just me,
but I think,
- Yeah they're pretty funny now.
- Like half my enjoyment when
clicking on a random video
is just going to the comment section.
- Its weird because I
feel like the whole like,
you know, commenting in a
meme format, in a meme video,
- [Connor] Yeah.
Its just like, I don't
know, people are just,
thinking to themselves, okay,
in order for me to stand out
in this absolute cesspool of
comments on this one video,
I actually need to be,
surprise, creative about it!
(Garnt laughing)
Otherwise I'm just gonna get
swept in with all these other,
like, meh comments, so now people,
now there's like this
weird pressure to be like,
'if I'm gonna comment on this meme video,
I gotta make it a fucking banger joke,
otherwise, no one's gonna like it
and its just gonna get buried.'
- And then you haven't
commented in the first hour
so you're not gonna be in
the top comments, anyway.
- Yeah, exactly.
(screen warping)
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- I know that none of
you watch porn, right?
- No, of course not. Ew!
- But just in case, you
have any friends that do,
you'll want to pay attention to this.
With everything going on in the world,
governments have increased
their surveillance,
they're using your device
to track your location,
movement and in many countries,
your internet activity.
- Disgusting.
- You don't want to be literally
caught with your pants down, do you,
(Joey laughing)
and one of the best ways to
keep your online browsing
that you do private,
is by using ExpressVPN!
- When you use ExpressVPN
your internet connection
is rerouted through a
secure, encrypted server
so you can surf the web anonymously,
without anyone looking over your shoulder.
- I know you're probably thinking that
all you have to do is use incognito mode
and no one can see that you've watched
every last hentai video on PornHub.
- Wait, that's, that's not how it works?
- You're wrong.
(Joey gasps)
Again, Joey,
- No!
- Even when you're using incognito mode,
your internet provider
like Comcast or AT&T
can see every single website you visit.
And if you live on
campus, or you share WiFi,
your network admin can, too.
Its kinda scary.
- That's why I use ExpressVPN
whenever I go online,
and I recommend all of you do the same.
Without ExpressVPN, you're
giving people a free license
to peek over your shoulder and frankly,
see all the freaky shit you're looking at.
- I will not stand for that,
and that's why I will get ExpressVPN.
So, protect your privacy today
and get 3 months of ExpressVPN for free.
Visit ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste ,
that's e x p r e s s v p n dot com, slash
Trash Taste.
- For 3 free months,
on a one year package,
its an insane deal, so
what are you waiting for?
Visit ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste
and learn more.
Back to the episode.
- So I'm curious. As content
creators and YouTubers,
- Yeah.
- Who have not given their feedback,
- As influencers.
(Connor scoffing)
- God, I hate that word.
- Who have not actually given
their feedback to YouTube,
- [Joey] Uh-huh.
- Is there anything you
would like to say to YouTube
to improve the platform?
Is there any actual feedback
you would like to give to YouTube.
- [Joey] Uhhhhhhhh.
- Apart from, and hopefully,
they'll actually hear us.
(Garnt laughing)
- Uhhhhhhhh. That's a good question.
I don't know.
- Yeah, because like, for
me, like, I don't know,
there's another system that's
just been recently implemented
and its the checking system.
- Ah, yeah.
- Like, I uploaded a
video recently and, so,
so, for those of you who don't know,
when you upload a video,
YouTube used to like,
some pre checks to make sure it was like,
content friendly, and content monetisable.
Now, those checks for
absolutely no reason,
just take, an hour plus.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] That's quite a while.
- I don't know if its because its like,
this new system is in
beta, or whatever, but,
- But I heard nothing about this,
they weren't transparent
about that at all.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I remember like,
the first time it happened on
one of my videos I was like,
oh no, am I in trouble?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- What's going on? Why,
- Like, diagnosing you.
- Why are there like,
fucking, enhance, enhance
this video to be like,
'we gotta find at least one frame
where we can fucking sic this guy.
- I don't know. I don't know who the fuck
is in charge of PR, but
why does it always feel
that when they like, tell us something,
finally, they tell us
something, and its like,
the dumbest shit.
(Garnt laughing)
Like, we didn't need to know
that dislikes are being removed,
- [Joey And Grant] Yeah.
- I, how about you just reply
to my emails when I'm like,
having a problem, like,
I think that's the one thing
is consistently been an issue
I think everyone talks
about, which is like,
communication and the fact
that when you have an issue,
that could be very simple,
becomes ten times more difficult
because YouTube's just like fuck you,
I'm not gonna talk to you.
- Yeah.
- And its like, well, you
know, and its not like you're,
not making decent money
for YouTube, you know,
- [Joey] Right.
- Even if its your living, it
feels like, well, you know.
- Well that's the thing, right?
Like, and that's the part
where I can't exactly
be like, wow YouTube,
I can't believe you ignore
us like that because I mean,
fuck, like, how many
channels are there now
that have over a million subs?
Like already that's like,
thousands and thousands and there is just,
probably all of those YouTubers
probably have at least
one period in their life,
where they're like,
I need you to reply to
me, so its like, I feel,
- How often do you need
to email YouTube for help?
Like, once a year at most.
- Yeah, maybe like, once or twice.
- So then like, at that level, right.
Let's say if there is like
some kind of mythical barrier,
its like, a million subs,
you get to have someone.
That doesn't seem too unreasonable to me.
But also I feel like, its
something that YouTube
just doesn't wanna do either.
- [Joey] Right.
- Like, they don't wanna fuck with that.
- And again like, you
know, that would be fine
if it was only those million plus subs
who even have access to
the YouTube email, right?
You know, you could have a channel
with fucking 10 subs be like,
'umm, YouTube why did you
delete my video, please help.'
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So its like,
- Yeah because most, you know,
if you are a YouTuber, right?
You're probably following an
account called Team YouTube
on Twitter.
- Yeah
- Which is like, YouTube customer support,
but not on their own fucking platform.
- But its a bot.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
and you know, you might tweet
them something that gets like,
tons of attention, tons
of stuff, and then,
they won't reply to it,
but they'll be replying
to someone who's like,
like, a bunch of other people who are like
'hey I got locked out of my account,'
and they're like, 'oh well,
here's how you can do it!'
- Its a bit fucked that
in order to get YouTube's
attention, you literally
have to ratio them.
- Yeah you do, I mean,
you have to spam them, its unfortunate.
- Yeah, you do, its like,
you just got ratio'd!
YouTube's like fuck, you got me.
All right, we'll help you out, bro.
- Its like, how well can you ratio?
That's how quickly we'll
reply to your email.
- But also you know, you know, like,
I've heard people who've
got immense amount of help
just because they, you know,
went to like, one YouTube event,
met a YouTube employee
and then they'll pull strings for you.
- Right.
- And that feels like,
its like, being in like, fucking prison,
its like, well your mate
knows the prison guard,
so you're not gonna get shanked.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Its like, what, how is that fair? Like,
I'm stuck in this system
and I have to work with you,
and I can't fucking do anything.
Its like, maybe I don't wanna
go to your fucking workshop,
YouTube? Have you thought about that?
Maybe I just want some help,
because my video got wronged.
- Because the only time I
ever got help from YouTube
was because I got very lucky
and I had a really good partner manager,
who's super super like, I think,
I think at the time
they were new to YouTube
and they were super down and like,
really be in depth and
talk with me and be like,
'hey, what do you need,
what do you need help with,'
and they were very nice and
helped me out a lot, you know.
And I was just sitting
there the whole time while
I was getting all this help,
I was like oh my god, like,
I sent how many fucking emails,
did so many other things.
We sent to so many people,
all it took was just one YouTube employee
who was nice to me, who
recommended me to like,
the engineering team or whatever,
- Yeah.
- And all my problems
got fixed, and its like,
this is so dumb that
this is what it takes.
- Yeah.
- To be like, I have to
have a man on the inside.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
to help me out.
- You need a double agent.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, like, its like, you know,
and they don't work there anymore,
so I don't even have the helping one,
so now I'm fucked with my issues.
- Now you're back to square one, right?
- I've just gotta like, cry on Twitter,
and I hate doing that. I
don't wanna be a child.
- Right.
- Do you know one feature on YouTube
that I do genuinely want removed?
- What.
- And I dunno if I would
be the only one here,
the 'your video is this ranked out of ten
of your previous ten videos.'
- [Joey] Ahh. Nah.
- Like, I understand it does serve a use,
but I don't, I don't know.
- I'm like, indifferent
to it, because its like,
it depends on how well
the video did really?
(Garnt laughing)
Where its like,
- That's the point!
- Yeah, where its like, where its like,
if I see a video and then its like,
'your video got less views
from your frequent viewers,
nine out of ten.' When its just like,
fuck the system. But then when its like,
'one out of ten,' then
you see those fireworks,
you're like, 'damn, I'm good!'
- I think we explain the
system about performance
to recap real quickly,
YouTube ranks your videos
and how they're doing
against your other videos,
the past ten videos, it
ranks them one out of ten.
One being the best, ten being the worst.
I actually quite like it.
- You like it?
- As much as I hate it, I like it.
I think its good, you know?
I, before, I remember,
did you used to have like,
an estimate in your head
of what was good views?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. For me, it was like,
if I get so-and-so views
in the first 24 hours,
good view. If its over that, great video.
Below that? Bad video.
- The problem with that is that, you know,
your average of what I
expect a video to get
is never static, and that
number is always changing,
and I think its good,
because I don't know what
I should be aiming for.
And at least this has
kind of helped me like,
set expectations and
figure out, okay, you know.
Its been a really good way
of figuring out personally,
all right, if something's number ten,
all right, let me go and reevaluate that.
Yeah it fucking sucks,
I'm not happy about it.
- Yeah.
- And sometimes I genuinely do think
it was that a really fucking good video
that got fucked by one reason or another.
But most of the time,
I do feel like its been really helpful.
As much as it makes me wanna just like,
quite YouTube.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I feel though, like, its
kind of a double-edged sword
in that case, though, because,
I remember where you know,
when you have like, say,
a really fucking good streak, right?
Of like, one to two months worth of videos
that are just banger
after banger after banger,
its like, all over performing.
- Its like the stock market, your bubble.
- Right, right!
- Your bubble's gonna pop.
- You know, you know the fall's coming.
- Yeah, and then you're like,
I'm expecting the fall, where's the fall
(Garnt laughing)
and then, you wake up the next morning
and your video's like nine out of ten,
or even like, a ten out of ten, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And you're like, well shit.
This is the end of my career.
- [Garnt] So this is what you do.
- And then, when you
look at that video, like,
in retrospect,
if you just say screw it
to the other nine videos,
let me just look at this video on its own.
- [Connor] Right.
- And its actually doing okay,
it just feels like the video is doing crap
because your other nine videos
were just over performing, right?
- You wanna hear a big brain strap?
Just make a shit video.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You gotta, you purposely
make a ten out of ten?
(Garnt laughing)
- Here's what I do,
right? Every now and then,
you know, as much as I
think all my ideas are,
you know, mostly good,
sometimes I'll make a video,
and it comes out shit.
And then I'm like, you know what? Fine.
Have a ten out of ten.
(Joey laughing)
Put my expectations down.
- Reset the expectations.
- I'm like, yeah, let's just fucking,
let's humble myself for a moment here.
Let's just upload a shit video.
I upload videos where I thought like,
oh my god, what am I doing,
and then like, I've also
had the opposite happen,
where I'm like, this is
a ten out of ten video,
and I'm like, this is garbage.
- Really?
- This is unwatchable, and it
literally got one out of ten,
and I'm like, I fucking hate
it here. This video sucked.
- I've had that before, as well.
- The worst ones are like, damn,
this is gonna be a banger video.
Nine out of ten.
(Garnt laughing)
- That, yeah.
- Ah, nothing feels worse than that.
- Nothing feels worse.
Like my entire like, I
check that in the morning
once a video goes up, I see
that, and I'm just like,
entire day ruined.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Just like that.
- I guess one other
thing is that maybe like,
I do see the usefulness in it,
so I don't think it should be removed, but
I think it should be harder to find,
because its like, front and center.
- It is literally the first thing you see.
- Literally the first thing
you see when you log in, right?
To your account. And YouTube's
either giving you a clap,
(Garnt clapping)
or being like, son, I
expected better from you.
(Joey laughing)
What the fuck is wrong.
- Man, I don't know, I
think it's all right.
I think where it is is fine, honestly.
- I think its just how you like,
personally perceive it, all right?
(Connor sighing)
- I think it very much takes a,
you have to kind of take
your emotions out of it
a little bit to really appreciate it.
- I mean, no.
- Which sounds so robotic, if you're like,
I think you just have to
appreciate the data for what it is.
Like.
- I mean,
- All it is, is neatly packaging
the truth you're hiding from yourself.
(Joey laughing)
in a way that is digestible
within 10 seconds.
You know what I mean?
- Well no, I think you know, that's the
healthy advice to be like, 'yo,
- You should just get over it.
(Garnt laughing)
- You should just not be sad.
- Stop being sad.
- Just don't be emotional,
just why you feeling emotions,
'cause like.
- You know, its just your
livelihood. Fuck off.
- I mean we've talked about
it before, like, how you know,
a lot of YouTubers before said
they don't care about
the views. But you know,
you do have, like, as
much as you want to think
that you're not emotionally
attached to your content
and the numbers around
your content, you do care.
- Its your job.
- At some level. You do care.
And its not like, I think you just have,
you would have to be a heartless robot
to make something you're proud of,
and not care about how
many people view it.
- The way I see it,
its that I don't care if I spill my drink,
but I do care if I spill my drink
and it wrecks my PC and
fucks everything up, right?
- Right.
- Like I feel there's an
acceptable amount of fucking up
that I'm like, 'ah, I'll
deal with that.' Right?
If I get one ten out of
ten, ah, well, all right
you know, it happens. Something's
gotta be ten out of ten.
Two ten out of tens in a
row, I'm like, all right.
(Garnt laughing)
You know, it happens sometimes, you know.
Three ten out of tens, I
will care, what is going on?
- [Joey] Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- That's when I start, that's
when it starts to affect me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But the first one, I don't
really let it affect me.
I'm like, you know what, just
statistics are just saying
that this is gonna
happen eventually, like.
- Right, no, I completely
get that, right, like,
of course, eventually
you're gonna have to get
a ten out of ten.
- I love math, and you
know, I appreciate it.
- Yeah. No I do too, don't get me wrong!
But like, you know.
I know, I know that
eventually this streak,
whatever it is I'm on, is gonna
eventually run out, right?
- Yeah, and you know, even
then, if you think about it,
right, the more you're
getting five out of tens,
six out of tens.
All you're doing is making
it closer and closer.
- [Joey] Right. Right.
- So if you're getting one out of tens
or tens out of tens every time,
you're making a like,
famine or feast situation.
Which is fine, but, what I'm at right now,
at least with my past few videos,
all been around like, give or take, like,
minimal percentage away from each other.
- Right.
- Like the difference between
third and eighth for me
is nothing. So like at
that point I'm like,
I don't even feel bad about any of it.
- Right.
Because I'm like, ninth or third,
its barely any difference to me
So why is YouTube trying to make me
fucking feel bad about
it. Stop that YouTube.
- No but, because there's another factor
that I feel like, this doesn't take like,
account for, and that's like,
a long term performance of a video.
- That's true.
- Because like, some of my
videos, some of my videos
that have been a nine, ten out of ten,
have gone on to grow into be like,
some of my most popular videos.
- That's true.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- And I feel like it,
what this system like,
really emphasizes, is how
well a video does short term.
(affirmative murmuring)
Whereas YouTube, as
like, a content creator
that has been on the platform
for a very long time,
I know that short term
performance doesn't mean a lot.
(affirmative murmuring)
but like, no matter what,
no matter if I make a video
that I'm proud of and I
think is gonna perform well
long term, I still feel shit about it
if it just is that nine or ten out of ten.
- No need, you need one out
of your whole channel uploads.
Like one out of like,
one thousand or however
many uploads you have.
- [Joey] Right.
I mean, I think that's
just going onto videos
and looking up most popular.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah but then you'll always feel good,
because you'll never have,
like, a lowest one ever again,
because you'll never have less
views. You know what I mean?
(Garnt laughing)
like, YouTube come on.
- Its like, whenever you're
feeling bad, just like,
lemme just go check out my
most viewed videos of all time.
You know what? I still got it.
(Joey laughing)
- Its like, okay, like,
I don't know if us talking about this,
I don't know how the viewers
feel about this being like,
wow this is such a first
world problems nowadays, like,
Jesus Christ, they're
complaining about this, but,
the reason like, I think
about it a lot is because.
Before this, I really did
not give a shit about, like,
I didn't, not that I didn't give a shit,
I didn't really put as much
focus on my mental health
- [Joey] Yeah.
until I started working
in a creative industry,
and then I realised, oh
shit my mental health
actually matters when it comes to my work.
Where before I would just
like, grind out my job,
feel like shit, but it
would be easy, right?
- And then drink the sadness
away at home, am I right?
(all laughing)
- And then drink the
sadness away, or just like,
fucking wait for the weekend,
you live for the weekend,
you reset.
- Yeah.
But now, its like a constant, okay,
I actually have to care about this thing,
otherwise it will literally affect
how well I'm performing at my job.
- I have no more weekends
and I'm constantly home.
- But like, not saying if
you have bad mental health
that you'll have an easy
time doing a job, but.
It's just like, in a creative job,
you really see the effects
of having bad mental health.
Which is why to me, like,
this, a system like this
to me, is like, you get more
Ls than Ws in my opinion.
- No, of course, absolutely.
- And its, its a system where
its like, you get that one W,
three times out of ten.
- I mean, its also because you know,
you're fighting in a system
that you have absolutely
no control over, right?
Its like, you can't
control whether a video
gets a ten or a one, like,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Its just, how it is, so
when you do get that one,
or you do get that dub, its
like, fucking three hundred
winning against the Persian Empire right?
(Garnt laughing)
its like, oh shit, I mean
I wasn't expecting it,
but fuck me I'll take it. You know?
- Little man's pulling through.
- Yeah, literally.
- You know what? There is
another feature on the whole
rating your videos and
how they perform thing,
which I don't actually quite like,
'cause I think its just,
the language they use
is just like, fuck off
- [Joey] Right.
- Its where its like,
this video is performing worse than usual.
- [Joey] Yeah!
- Yeah!
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I hate that.
- Its like my mum talking to me, I'm like,
I wish I could just put it
in like, another language,
like fuck off, I don't
wanna read this shit.
- Yeah. Its like that
passive aggressive note
that's left on the fridge when
you're living in university.
- Yeah, its like, motherfucker,
I know how to read a graph.
I don't need you to tell me. Its like,
the like, there is one curve
that is lower than the other.
This curve is lower than the other,
that means its doing worse.
And I'm like, no shit its doing,
that's typically how graphs work.
(Garnt laughing)
It tells you information.
- What I hate is that it starts
off with the layman's terms
of like, this is performing
worse than usual.
And then it goes on to be like,
its performing 40%, 7% less.
You didn't, you could have just
got rid of that first part,
you coulda just said
its performing 47% less.
And I would've.
- Its the pandering language that
YouTube tries to use of like,
'yeah, we care about you,'
(Joey laughing)
- 'We hear you.'
- Its like, this isn't an
intervention, but it could be.
- Yeah.
- So sort your shit out.
(Garnt laughing)
Its frustrating.
- How do you guys feel
about the algorithm itself?
- I don't give a fuck anymore.
- I don't even know what
it is at this point.
Like, you know, again, its like.
- Yeah, when you grow,
right, you give a fuck,
you're like, write that down,
like, any time MatPat would say anything,
you're like, fuck, write that down.
- Yeah. Whenever you're
growing you're like,
well shit, I need to be listening to this.
Other wise I'm gonna be stuck
in my sub count forever.
- [Connor] Yeah.
But when you get to a
certain point and you can
just kinda make whatever
the hell you want.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Its just like, I feel
like I've figured it out,
and then some days its just like,
'nope that's not how that works.'
- Yeah.
- I mean I feel like every creator,
at least that's been around for a while.
And I feel like this is probably like,
a reason you do stay around a while,
is that you just stop valuing
getting crazy sub growth.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And just being like,
I just wanna make good shit
that just maintains what I have.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You know, I don't think
that you need to keep growing,
we will keep growing,
but its not something I really care about.
- Well that's my mentality of its like,
at the end of the day, if I see
that I have more subs
at the end of the day
than I did at the beginning of the day,
whether that's one sub
or ten thousand subs,
its like well, I'm still here, I guess.
- I feel like, I feel like, as a YouTuber,
the hard part is getting to around like,
100k to 500k subscribers,
and I feel like, you know,
because luck plays such a big part.
- Yeah.
- In that, and getting your
videos on the algorithm itself.
But I feel like, once you
get to around that size,
it like, becomes more predictable
than people give it credit for.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You know, because at that point,
it becomes more like a game, right?
Where you know what's gonna perform well,
(affirmative murmuring)
you kinda know what's gonna perform well.
And sometimes you get this
lucky hit where you just
like, I don't know why
this video's doing so well,
but most of the time, if
you get to a past 100k,
you can kind of predict how,
what you need to do to grow.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- If you understand what
the system, at least.
- [Joey] Yeah.
(affirmative murmuring)
- If you understand the platform.
- This episode is
sponsored by Mack Weldon.
- Gamers, this year, spring is
gonna hit a little different.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
because we're all starting
to finally get outside
and see friends again.
- No matter where your
adventures take you,
bring the comfort and style of Mack Weldon
along for the ride.
Trust me, your closet
is going to thank you.
- Whether its their hoodies,
polos, tees or active shorts,
everything in the Mack Weldon collection
mixes and matches seamlessly to fit in
with any other trendy products you have.
I'm actually wearing the Mack
Weldon underwear right now.
- Socks, shirts, hoodies,
underwear, polos or active shorts,
Mack Weldon promises comfort
and a consistent fit.
- And with the world of Blue program,
a totally free loyalty program,
Level One gets you free
shipping, for life,
and once you reach Level
Two by spending $200,
you get 20% off every
order for the next year.
- And don't forget about
the Mack Weldon guarantee?
Mack Weldon wants you to be comfortable,
so if you don't like your
first pair of underwear,
you can keep them, and
they'll still refund you,
no questions asked.
- So, what are you waiting for?
For 20% off your first order, visit
MackWeldon.com/TrashTaste
and enter promo code TrashTaste.
That's Mack Weldon dot
com, slash Trash Taste.
Promo code, TrashTaste for 20% off.
Mack Weldon, reinventing men's basics.
- Back to the episode.
- I feel like its always about, you know,
to get to the million, you know,
you have to go through the proving ground
(affirmative murmuring)
like, to get to that size
you have to consistently
prove to YouTube that you can make content
that is engaging to people.
Then I feel like you
can just kinda be like,
all right, well, you know, I feel like,
it feels like less effort
'cause you just know
what you're doing.
- Yeah.
(affirmative murmuring)
You feel like, I put
less thought into things,
I'm like, oh, you know,
I know that won't work,
inherently like, just by looking at stuff,
I'm like, that's a bad thumbnail,
that's a bad title, you know?
- Yeah.
- And then you can just kind of like,
not take it easy, but you
can focus more on just,
having a healthy work schedule,
- [Joey] Right.
- I mean, we've said this
before a hundred times
and I'm sure everyone can
figure it out, you know,
when you first start out its
brutal, the hours you put in.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- For nothing.
(Connor laughing)
- But I also like, you know,
- For like $2 ff you're lucky.
- Yeah.
- But I also like, I remember, you know,
back in the day when I was still growing,
I never once thought to
myself, 'that's a good title',
or 'that's a bad title', 'that's a good',
'that's a bad thumbnail', right?
- I just tried to explain the video,
and then I was like, wait,
that's not how it works.
- I was just like,
here is an image of game
with number in the corner.
- Episode 7. Done.
- I'd be like,
'The Sebastian Call Where
the Girl Gets Excited'
- Yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- And it was like, well that's
not. That's not a good title.
And I started changing it up.
- Yeah, but past you was like,
'I mean, now people know
what this video is,' right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I feel like the
platform has changed a lot
since we started growing.
- You could get away with
doing the parts before,
- Yeah.
- You can't do parts.
- No. Not anymore.
- You can't do video parts now.
- Unless you have, like,
a massive series that people
are really waiting for.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Like, we say parts, but
fucking Trash Taste is parts.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
we've literally put
numbers on each of them.
(Joey laughing)
- I mean that's just for ease, isn't it?
To keep track of it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I mean its kinda like, I mean
its parts but you can enjoy each part.
I mean, I don't even call it a part.
Its an episode number, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
(affirmative murmuring)
- And you can enjoy
each episode, by itself,
and then there are also
people who are just like,
are like, totally ingrained in like,
the Trash Taste lore,
whatever the fuck that is.
(Joey laughing)
I go onto our subreddit
sometimes and I'm just like,
man, the amount of layers that new like,
viewers would have to understand
just to get this one meme
is fucking ridiculous.
- We literally have a chronological order,
and a fucking, like, a lore order.
(all laughing)
Where its like, no its watching order
and chronological order.
- Because like, the
Trash Taste lore, like,
watching our subreddit goes
beyond just our channel now.
It just like, everyone
we've ever interacted with
is now part of the Trash Taste lore.
(Joey laughing)
- True.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
- Its hilarious.
- I find it like, I find it impressive
how people have just like,
been able to create this like,
because its not even like, its
not even logically laid out.
People just have this
unwritten understanding that
'Okay, yeah, this is part
the Trash Taste lore,
and part of the Trash Taste group.'
- Right, the only other like,
group I've seen this dedicated is like,
people who are into the
Nasuverse, where its like.
(Garnt laughing)
Its just like,
- Wow. Call just me out, Joey.
- What's the Nasuverse.
- Its a fake lore.
- Its the fake.
- Its like, they're fucking
pulling it from like,
literally nowhere that has
anything to do with anything,
being like, 'well, I mean
Garnt did say this thing
on this like, tiny like,
YouTuber's podcast,
like, six years ago,
I'm pretty sure this has
a connection somewhere
to one of these episodes.' Where its like.
- Its weird man, it
feels like the first time
on YouTube where people actively
care about what I'm doing.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Like, doesn't that sound strange?
Like, before I just felt
like no one gave a shit
what I was up to.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
Just do my own thing.
Now I feel like, people actually like,
watch when I do something,
and like, whoa, this is weird.
- Well that's the thing, its like,
I've noticed that whenever I
go onto the subreddits like,
half of these posts
have nothing to do with
the actual Trash Taste episodes.
Its like, its either drawn
from like, someone's Twitter
or someone's Twitch,
or a guest's Twitter or a guest's Twitch.
(Garnt laughing)
Its like, or like, a friend
of one of the host's like,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
What?
- Its kind of cool, though.
- I mean, I'm not saying
this is a bad thing,
- No, no, its dope as fuck.
- I'm just, like.
- I just find it really interesting
that it became like that.
- No, what I find really interesting,
that people are able to
follow along, with this,
even though there's like,
there's no fucking coherent watch order?
- [Joey] No.
- You know?
- Yeah.
- Now we've gone to the point
you can watch every episode
of Trash Taste and still
not understand everything
going on in the subreddit, right.
- [Joey] No, of course.
Because then you have
to follow our content,
you have to follow other people's content,
other people's Twitter, and I'm just like,
god fucking damn, man, respect to you.
- Yeah. Honestly. Its cool.
- I'm just so confused.
I'm on this podcast and
I don't know the lore.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I can't keep up with the
shit that's been going on.
- I don't know what's canon
and what's not canon anymore.
- Like what is canon, what is not canon.
Its just, I just view it as
one of the people in like,
the fucking lore, and
I'm just like, damn man.
What is going on right now.
- I guess I did say or
do that, I don't know.
- Everyone's just calling
me a VTuber simp now,
that's all they call me now.
That's what they're saying.
- Yeah that's been the hot meme.
Yeah, we just did this episode again
by just saying that right
now, the big hot meme
on the Trash Taste subreddit
is Connor making every VTuber
he interacts with into a Connor simp.
(Connor laughing)
Essentially.
Which is hilarious, because you were the,
I've seen this fucking
screenshot everywhere.
Whenever someone mentions that like,
you're the Vtuber simp, now, being like,
this one screenshot that just says
'I don't understand VTubers.'
- I still kinda don't, like.
- Meanwhile every VTuber's like,
well, I understand you.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I don't know,
I really enjoy collaborating with VTubers
and talking to them.
I think, mainly from the aspect of like,
you know, I don't particularly care about
the character themselves,
or who they're playing.
I think just as a content creator myself,
I find it really interesting
what it takes to play a
character like that permanently.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And its normally, you know,
when you talk to the VTubers,
if I talk to them offline, where you know,
you normally get some really
interesting bits of information
just about how, you
know, they like, prepare,
or how they think about it,
and I just find that really fascinating.
(affirmative murmuring)
And I think, you know,
when you're collaborating with
a VTuber, I don't know why,
I think there's a really
interesting dynamic
that you can work off really well,
if its one Vtuber and
one like, IRL person.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Yeah.
- Where, although I think a lot of,
maybe diehard VTuber fans
will think 'no! Never!'
You know.
- 3D and 2D do not mix.
(affirmative murmuring)
- I think there is some really
interesting room for like,
really fun and interesting collaborations
that come across because of the 2D-3D mix.
- [Joey] Well, I mean.
- I completely agree, because, like,
I kind of remember when
Ladybeard was on like,
now a few weeks ago I guess.
But I remember like,
hearing his story and
hearing how he goes about,
you know, his character
and his stage presence,
and everything like that. I was just like,
yeah I kinda think VTubers,
I said VTubers were wrestling with waifus,
and after talking to
Ladybeard I'm just like,
yeah I kinda, I kind of
agree with myself more now.
(Joey laughing)
- God. Cognitive dissonance.
I found something that proves my point.
Thus, it is correct. No,
I do agree, you know.
I mean, I, you know,
I spoke to some of your
VTubers, and, you know,
you hear so many different
reasons why they became VTubers,
like, 'oh, I just wanted easy money',
- [Joey] Yeah.
or 'oh, I really, really
liked this character',
or, I've always, you know,
or 'I can't do anything with
my face, I'm too anxious,'
or, yeah. Everyone has their own reason
and its really fucking
cool to hear about that.
And, get to know the people
behind it, sometimes.
- Yeah.
- I feel the like, especially
recently, like, you know,
maybe still in Japan, there
might still be a thing of
'oh, you know, 2D and 3D
shouldn't mix,' you know, like.
(affirmative murmuring)
'IRL and VTubers should
never do stuff together
'cause it breaks the
immersion' blah blah blah.
But I feel in the West,
especially recently,
I feel that idea is
slowly starting to fade,
because, especially, you
know, if we're look at like,
VShojo, right. Like, they're
doing a lot more like,
collaboration with IRL streamers.
Like, Nyanners did that whole thing
where they did a tour of Japan, right?
- [Garnt] Right.
- [Connor] Oh.
- And that was IRL, and
I think just yesterday,
as of this episode,
Anthony Padilla did like, a
'I spent a day with VTubers.'
(affirmative murmuring)
- They actually had a clip of Trash Taste,
of the Cali episode.
- Oh really?
- On that.
Hell yeah. Yeah and I just feel
like, at least in the West,
sure there still might be a
lot of diehard VTuber fans
who don't want that illusion
to be broken, or whatever.
But, I feel the majority
of them are kinda just like
'well, I mean, let's not
kid ourselves.' Right?
Like, these are also
people, and, you know,
I think its cool to see
this, like, really weird,
two different worlds completely
clashing with one another.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- In a really cool way.
- 'Cause like, I will say like,
I have been watching less VTubers
as 2021 has rolled around.
- [Joey] Right.
- Part of the reason of that is that
anime has gotten really,
really good again.
So I've just had.
(Connor laughing)
- Sorry, I've skipped the waifus, back to,
- Back to the scripted ones.
(all laughing)
- But also its less that
I've just been watching
less VTubers, but I've just
been watching more streamers
in general, now.
(affirmative murmuring)
Not even watching streams,
but watching like,
the stream highlights
and the stream content
that has been posted on YouTube.
- [Joey] Right.
- Because I feel like, there
is a definite difference
between hololive and VShojo,
right? Because I feel like,
VShojo are VTubers who are streamers,
and I feel like hololive
is definitely more like,
treated as idols.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And what I found is that I kind of
more gravitated towards seeing
VTubers as content creators,
like, I just respect
them as content creators.
More than anything, and like, I, you know,
I've never understood idol anime,
or like, the idol kind
of industry itself, so.
That's why I've gravitated more
towards VTubers who I think
are just like, beyond anything,
are just talented content creators.
And just, doing good content.
- And I think that might be
one of the bigger reasons,
why nowadays,
I'm watching a lot of the
streamers from NijiSanji.
(affirmative murmuring)
Because again, like, its not so much,
they kind of treat their
VTubers, again, like streamers.
Like, actual content
creators, because they don't,
they're not really seen.
I'm sure there are people
who view Nijisanji YouTubers
as idols, quote unquote, but.
- [Garnt Yeah.
- I feel, just been in,
like, a lot of live streams
of all sorts of Nijisanji creators,
there are definitely
a lot more, just like,
just people, or like,
streamers, or content creators,
who are just here to have,
shoot the shit and just have a fun time.
(affirmative murmuring)
yeah, again, like,
I feel there's like, a
different of enjoyment to that,
as well as you know, how hololive is
kind of seen in that sense, and like.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I'm not saying one is better
than the other, personally,
but I just think its a
really interesting dynamic,
because people just think,
'oh if you're a VTuber,
you're immediately like, hololive',
or 'you're immediately like,
VShojo', you're just kind of,
thrown into this like, single basket of
'you are this type of content creator
with this type of fan base.'
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- When, in reality, its
very very different,
depending on how, I guess,
you treat your character?
Yeah. Its kind of weird.
- Even in hololive, even in
the hololive agency itself,
there are like, a lot
of streamers in hololive
are doing like, very,
very different content.
(affirmative murmuring)
But I think the difference
is, now, that, you know,
2020 was the year of the VTuber.
- [Joey] Yep.
- Or hololive's year, right?
(Connor laughing)
- There's just like, there'll
be the year of the Zodiac.
- The year of the Vtuber.
- I mean, it kind of was.
- I'm year of the VTuber.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- I mean, 2020 was,
the year of the VTuber.
- Yeah.
- The difference between
like, the hype is,
I mean obviously there's,
the viewership's still there,
the craze that was there.
- The growth has like,
slowed out a little bit.
- Its definitely gonna be harder,
to grow as a VTuber.
- Yeah.
- Even in an agency like hololive now
because there's so much
competition out there.
- Its like the gold rush is already like,
- Yeah the golden age is
kind of over, right? Yeah.
- I think this year has really, for me,
separated like, VTubers, not just VTubers,
but streamers who are doing like,
really really interesting
content and just,
(affirmative murmuring)
interesting ideas vs you
know, a Vtuber who, you know,
doesn't put as much thought
into their content, maybe?
(affirmative murmuring)
And just, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I was trying to find
a nice way to word that.
(all laughing)
- The good ones from the bad
is what you're trying to say?
- Not the good ones from the bad,
but just,
- The stronger ones?
- The ones who really view this as like,
as content, and just like,
as an entertainment platform.
Rather than.
- And not just as like, a gimmick, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
Because I feel like,
the gimmick part is over
now, the gimmick era is over,
and if you want to grow as a VTuber now,
you need to have solid content.
- Right. And I think its because, like,
you know, the idea of
VTubing as a gimmick now,
is just so, just common knowledge, now,
that whenever a new VTuber comes out,
(affirmative murmuring)
not as many people are like
'oh my god, did you see this?
Its like, a virtual person on
my stream right now,' like,
everyone knows what a VTuber is now.
- I'm like, so curious about
where this is gonna go.
You know, we're in a good spot right now,
where I feel like, its in like,
the middle period, if you will.
- Yeah.
- Like, everything's pretty
chill, things all good,
- Yep.
- I'm really interested to see
how the community in general
will handle things like, all right,
what if a VTuber wants to quit.
What if a VTuber wants to show their face,
(affirmative murmuring)
and just start streaming like that?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You know. When the stuff,
'cause this hasn't happened yet,
like, I've clearly,
do you know of any VTubers
who have been like,
yeah fuck VTube, like, big VTubers,
and they've been like, fuck this
I'm gonna show my face
and do normal streaming.
- Probably the one that comes to mind
is Kizuna AI. The original one.
- Right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But that's different,
though, I feel like,
- I mean, she wasn't
considered like, a streamer.
Like, she wasn't a YouTuber,
(affirmative murmuring)
You're talking about like,
- Yeah.
- Like, the VTubers right now. Right?
- I mean there's been a
lot of Nijisanji VTubers
who have quit, for no reason.
- Like, some, I wonder if
its no reason or you know,
NDAs have been signed, you can't say.
- Well no, actually there was
one where she openly was like,
I'm quitting just because I've
found something else to do.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like, its nothing like,
I've no bad blood or anything,
and I can say that contractually,
I just wanna quit because
I have something new to do.
(affirmative murmuring)
and everybody in that fan base
took it really, really well.
They were like, 'well, its
gonna suck that you're gonna
go, but, at least all your
old content is still here.'
Right? Like, 'good luck bro' kinda thing.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Well that's good,
yeah, I mean, obviously,
at some point I can imagine there,
'cause there's agencies and agencies
aren't always the best, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I mean, there's probably
gonna be a messy breakup,
if you will, at some point, right?
- Oh I mean like, that
has been in the past,
but honestly I don't wanna
get into that shit right now.
(affirmative murmuring)
- I don't even know about that,
- I don't of messy breakups
that have happened, yeah.
Because of agency stuff,
but, a lot of that is like,
its kinda just like, well I mean,
its an agency we're
dealing with and you know,
they're trying their best to
sweep everything under the rug.
Like, I don't even wanna
deal with that shit
to be honest with you.
- Let's not dig that stuff up.
- Yeah, let's not dig
that stuff up, right,
its their problem, fuck this.
- Yeah.
- I won't ask.
- Because like, I'm just
interested to see how the
I mean, how the industry grows.
- Its so new, right?
Is it gonna be VTuber
apology videos, you know?
(Connor laughing)
if so, will there be a deep sigh,
will they look into the camera?
These are the things I wanna know. Like,
- Yeah.
- I feel like, re-watching
YouTube evolve but like,
on like, ten times speed.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- Its like, its so new and
like, nothing's been defined,
the rules aren't set in stone.
Everyone's kinda doing their own thing.
(affirmative murmuring)
and its kind of Wild West right now.
- Yeah.
- And its, I just love watching it,
and just hearing about it.
(affirmative murmuring)
Its so fascinating for
that reason, and you know,
like I said, I don't really watch VTubers,
I watch my friends,
because I'm like, you know,
gotta, gotta support your friends.
- Yeah.
- And, because like, one thing
that I always think about,
and one reason why I could like,
never like, be a VTuber
myself is I think about it,
and like, part of like, what
I love about being a YouTuber
and making content where
people know who I am
is being able to meet fans and
being able to meet people at conventions,
stuff like that.
(affirmative murmuring)
and I just think, you know,
especially with conventions and AX stuff,
and you know, every public
meeting cancelled last year,
and possibly this year as well.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I'm sad because like,
I don't get to get the,
what's the word I'm looking for,
- Interaction?
- I don't get to get the interaction.
- Oh I'd never thought about that.
- Because at the end of the day, like,
there's, looking at numbers
means nothing to me, right?
- Meeting the people and meeting the fans.
- Yeah, true.
- A lot of times, it resets, like,
it reminds me the reason why I do this.
(affirmative murmuring)
why I love doing this, right?
- Like, months of stress
can be wiped out by
one weekend of just, meeting fans, like.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like, I don't know man,
its just, like, its,
- Its so wholesome.
- Its like, a rewarding
experience that you'll never,
its so unique.
- It gives you something tangible, right?
Like, for all the work that you've done.
- Yeah.
- And I just think, man. I
can't imagine being a YouTuber,
a VTuber and just never
being able to meet fans.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, in person, right? And just,
- Knowing there's a, so
many people who like,
love you and what you do, and
like, everything about you,
you can never say like,
- There is like, weirdly no
better feeling than just, like,
minding your own business going out,
and then someone stopping
you on the street being like,
'I fucking love you.'
- Yeah.
- Because like, because I mean,
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
that sounds a bit weird out of context.
- Its just like, very bizarre.
(Garnt laughing)
- It sounds weird out of context
but I have had fan
relationships like that.
- Yeah.
- But like, yeah, but like, as a VTuber,
no one knows what you look like, right?
- Even in some universe
where you could meet fans,
like, they would expect
you to be this character.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- Do they actually like you
or do they like this
character they're playing?
- [Joey] Or like the character, yeah.
- Its this, its a weird dynamic
that I can't imagine myself having.
- Well its like,
- I guess we appreciate that, right?
- Yeah.
- But I, you know, there's some YouTubers,
some VTubers out there that probably like,
the last thing they ever
wanna do is meet anyone.
(all laughing)
- [Joey] Right. And I feel,
- Which I get, you know?
- And I feel we can say that you know,
we might not be able to experience that,
and aw its sad that they
can't experience that
because, you know, we've
experienced, you know,
fans coming up to us and
liking us and praising us,
for who we are, and how
we should ourselves.
(affirmative murmuring)
But you know, I mean, I don't know,
there might be some VTubers out there
who have probably never
experienced that, right?
So they probably don't even know the joy.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Of that. They just think,
well of course the only fan
interactions I'm gonna have
is people who like my character.
- Um OnlyFans.
- And that's fine.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Fucking ten years old.
- What are you, twelve?
- Sorry!
(Garnt laughing)
- You're the most mature one here, Garnt.
- Sorry I just completely ruined your.
- You're the same person who
plays Pokemon and is like,
'ha ha, they said pee pee.'
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- 'PP up.'
- 'PP up' ah hah.
(Garnt laughing)
- No but like, you know, because I feel
if a VTuber went from
traditional YouTubing
where they get that
kind of fan experience,
to then go onto VTubing,
and get a completely different
type of fan experience.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Then sure, you know,
there might be like,
'ah fuck, I mean, this
fan interaction is cool,
but its not the same kind of you know,
gratification I got when it was just me
in front of a camera,' right?'
(affirmative murmuring)
But to a love of these VTubers,
they don't know any better,
so they're probably just like,
'well, yeah, of course, people
like me for my character,'
and they probably don't
give a shit, you know,
for me its, I feel its
the same as you know,
people going up to voice
actors and actresses,
and being like, 'I love
you because you played
this character.'
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I feel its the exact same thing.
- Its like, to them, that's,
they're probably expecting that.
- Yeah. Its weird because
I obviously look at this
from a content creator's
perspective, and you know,
if I did ever get the chance
to meet any VTubers I really liked,
(affirmative murmuring)
I would like, 'just wanted to say,
love the fucking content you're doing,'
I also find it really fascinating,
the kind of like, mindset you have to be
to be this kind of content creator.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Yeah.
- Because its such a different field
from what we're doing, and I don't know,
its just really interesting to me.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Is this what it feels like, when like,
a parents is like,
(Garnt laughing)
is like, 'I don't get this
whole YouTubing thing,
but it must be very difficult.'
I can't, I could never
see myself doing it.
- I mean, that's what I really,
I really respect streamers,
because they do something
that I find fucking difficult
to do, like, I don't know how.
- And I'm sure its vice versa
for the streamer, right?
- Yeah I don't know how you
go home and stream sometimes,
Connor, I'm just like,
I go home, I'm done.
- I sleep.
- Yeah
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah I don't know how
you go home and sleep,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
look at you, you disgust me.
I don't know, I just
like, I like it. Its fun.
I don't know, I like talking.
- It seems fun, it seems like,
the streaming sphere
right now, it seems like,
its just fun, it just seems like, its.
You get more chance to
just, really collaborate
and make friends as
well, which is one thing
I'm really jealous about.
- I don't know if its because
I'm paying more attention to
streaming, it just seems like,
its in a really good place right now.
- I think it is. Its funny
because I think streaming
is in a really good place,
I think Twitch is like.
We've complained about YouTube,
- No, Twitch is terrible.
- But my god, Twitch as
a platform, Jesus Christ.
- Oh yeah. Yeah, it is, almost,
just, from how I see it,
it seems like, its
almost fucking impossible
to grow on Twitch as like,
someone who's coming from nothing.
- Wait, do you guys know why
are all the VTubers on YouTube?
Why is most, at least,
at least Japanese ones.
Why are they all on YouTube?
- Because YouTube, I feel, or
I mean this is just my guess,
but I feel its because YouTube,
to a Japanese audience,
is a lot more well-known than Twitch is.
- [Connor] Ah.
- I feel Twitch, I mean,
not to say that there aren't
massive Japanese streamers
on Twitch, there are.
And some of them pull
insane fucking numbers,
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But I feel its just two
completely different worlds like,
I don't. This is just my guess
but I feel for a regular Japanese
viewer of content online,
you stick only to one
website, and that's it.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Whereas like, you know, I feel its like,
if you're a YouTube watcher,
you are exclusively a YouTube watcher.
If you're a Twitch watcher,
you're a Twitch watcher.
If you're a Niconico watcher,
you're only on Niconico.
(affirmative murmuring)
Whereas, I feel that same
mentality doesn't work
for a Western viewer, right?
Like, A Western viewer will be like,
'well yeah, I'm gonna watch
some content on YouTube,'
- I go where the content is.
- Well yeah, but like, I
can also go onto Twitch
if I want to, right?
(affirmative murmuring)
- Yeah, I guess so.
= I don't know, maybe.
- Yeah, I mean, for me, I
hardly watch any Twitch at all,
on the Twitch platform,
but I think what's becoming
more common now is like,
Twitch and YouTube are becoming
more and more intertwined,
(affirmative murmuring)
where like, a lot of, some
of the most popular content,
and some of the most original
content as well, right now,
has been Twitch highlights.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And that's why I've grown way more of
an appreciation for Twitch, like,
I still spend very little
time on the platform,
as a consumer, but, I end up consuming
a lot of Twitch content on YouTube,
which is why I think like,
one of my favourite
content creators right now
is probably Ludwig?
(affirmative murmuring)
Where he's just doing like,
the subathon that he's
doing right now is insane.
- Insane.
- Fucking insane.
- Definitely over by now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah. Definitely.
Hopefully is over by now.
(Joey laughing)
My god.
- I was like, are you gonna
like, die on camera, like?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Is that when the subathon ends?
- Sleeping on camera is like,
one of the most bizarre
things for me to like,
think about doing.
- Do you wanna explain
what, who Ludwig is?
- Yeah, so Ludwig used to be very big
in the Smash community.
(affirmative murmuring)
and then moved to
streaming and became like,
An instant hit.
- Yeah.
- Streaming.
He's very funny, very
naturally charismatic.
- He's just a natural born entertainer.
- Yeah. And he did a
thing where every sub,
it adds 10 seconds I believe?
- Something like that.
- So every time someone
subscribes to his Twitch channel,
10 seconds gets added,
and it went up to like,
you know, 70 hours at one point.
- Yeah. So, the big
difference is that, he made.
Normally in a subathon,
you cap the number of hours
that you can possibly stream for a time.
He made the stream stream
uncapped and I think,
right now, he's been
streaming for over a week?
Continuously?
- Ah, its like, two weeks, I think.
- Something like that.
- Was it two weeks?
(affirmative murmuring)
- And he just sleeps on stream.
And that's something to me, that I'm like,
dude, what the fuck, just like,
I like, say things in my sleep. Like,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I don't know what you say in your sleep.
- Dude, listen, listen.
I don't say anything bad.
But what if its the one day
where I say something bad.
(all laughing)
- One, day where you
have that one nightmare.
- Does it count if you're
racist in your sleep?
Does that count?
- When you have that one
racist nightmare, right?
(Garnt laughing)
- Like, what if right,
you're listening to like,
that, you know, that GTA,
or the modser clip where,
you know, they say the thing, you know?
- What if you go to bed and
then you just say it out loud
when you're sleeping.
Can you be cancelled for
being racist in your sleep?
- I don't know. Okay.
- If that actually happened,
would you be cancelled if
someone said, you know,
the thing in their sleep?
- Depends if you're a VTuber or not.
VTubers are just like,
that word is just like,
free game.
(affirmative murmuring)
every VTuber has that
past for some reason.
Especially if they're Japanese, but uh.
- Yeah but what if you're
a white guy, you know.
(Garnt laughing)
Ludwig's sleeping and then he sleeps,
he's talking and then
he says that, you know?
Do you get cancelled?
- God. There's a part of me that says
'that's ridiculous, of course not,'
but then another part of me is like,
'nah, he would definitely get cancelled.'
- Can you be cancelled for your dreams?
(Garnt laughing)
- That's like, some George Orwell shit.
- Well like, do you have control of your,
what does it say about you if,
- Call up the dream police!
- If you say a racist thing
in your dream are you racist?
- (Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I'm about make a dream TwitLonger.
- Deadass, right?
- The site for dream police.
(Garnt laughing)
- Wait until it happens.
Its gonna happen,
and no one's gonna fucking
know how to deal with it.
- Oh my god.
- I'm just imagining like,
the plot of Inception,
instead of like, putting in an idea,
just go in the dream just
to cancel them in the dream.
- There'll be two camps, there'll be like,
the camp that believes
like, you know, okay,
well he just said it in his dream.
There'll be another team like,
'I bet he's secretly awake and said it,'
(Garnt laughing)
'because he's racist.'
- Nobody says that in their sleep,
unless he's awake.
- Because he's awake, and racist!
(Garnt laughing)
This is a really weird tangent,
I just thought, you know.
- I think its a very valid
thought experiment, though!
- Its a very valid thought.
- I you know, I never do I ever,
ever wanna say bad words like that.
- I just wanted to, like, to all respect,
how the fuck was that the
first thing you thought of?
- Listen. Because no, no, no, no.
- When you saw someone sleeping on stream.
- My, what I see when I
see sleeping through stream
as a content creator, I just think like,
everything that could go wrong.
Like, what if I shit myself in my sleep?
- Everything can be taken outta context.
- What if I do a rip, an
absolute massive fart.
Like, the wettest thing.
Just like, any of the stuff that could
reasonably happen in your
sleep that is totally normal.
- Yeah.
- Not being racist in your sleep,
I don't know if that's
normal. Probably isn't.
But like, you know.
- Not that I would know.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You know, and like,
he takes his shirt off
when he was sleeping and you
know, what if you just like,
'cause you know, sometimes, you
fucking throw the sheets off
when you're sleeping, right?
- Oh you sleep naked as well, don't you?
- Well I don't sleep, well, it depends.
- What if I just pop a
nut on screen, right?
(Garnt laughing)
- Or if you get, you
know, you're lying down,
you got a morning wood.
Big, big boner, you know?
- Yeah.
Like, right on stream, 4K.
You're like, what, you
get banned for that? Like,
I'm just literally thinking,
the stuff that you would never ever think
would ever happen normally
when you're sleeping.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah.
- But just suddenly become like,
this is my number one rule
now when I'm sleeping.
- No it is valid, it is valid.
- I mean, there's a lot of
things you don't think about.
- Because you can't control it, you know!
- Yeah.
There's a lot of things,
because with YouTube,
we could easily edit stuff
out if we'd said something,
- Yeah.
- Just wanna, just wanna
say if I shat myself,
I would own it by the way.
- On stream?
- I would, yeah, I would shit.
- I mean like, I feel like
the possibly worst thing
that could happen on
stream when you're asleep
is that you just utter
a racist word, you know?
I'm just thinking, yeah.
- Would you rather utter
a racist word asleep
or shit yourself?
- Id rather shit myself.
- I'd rather shit myself.
- Really? Shit yourself on
stream? That's great content!
- You're not gonna get
cancelled for that, if anything,
you'll be immortalised on the internet
as the one dude who shit farted himself.
- Think about the amount of subs
you'd get for shitting
yourselves on stream.
(Joey laughing)
- I could just see it, you
know, you say something racist,
you end up on FOX being
like, 'liberals are trying to
cancel this man, for being
racist in his sleep!'
- I'm just imagining what if, like,
a VTuber shit themselves on stream.
Can you imagine the super Chat for that?
- No, it would be like,
'I'm weirdly turned on.
Here's 500 bucks.'
- Thanks for that. I needed that.
- Oh my god. How do we,
we've gone on a really weird tangent.
- It was the subathon.
- Ah, the subathon,
yeah I mean, I've like,
- Twitch content's gone crazy.
- Talking about like, watching him sleep,
and just like, the Chat going
crazy and stuff like that,
I watch it and I'm
like, weirdly engrossed.
Not because he's sleeping,
just because of like, the reaction itself.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Of like, how active this Chat is, right?
And I'm just like, man,
this is literally just The Truman Show,
we are watching The
Truman Show happen to us.
(Joey laughing)
- But he can't leave his room.
At least in The Truman
Show you can walk around.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah. That's true. But I mean,
this is kinda like the closest
we've had to The Truman Show.
And its, fascinating.
- It would drive me insane
- Its a fucking Black
Mirror episode. It is.
- And its fucked. Its fascinating.
- Yeah. But its also like, I
just, find it really weird that
I don't know what the mentality
of people is, where like,
you watch this dude sleeping on stream,
and you think to yourself
'I'ma drop a hundred subs.'
While he's asleep. Because
like, normally, you know,
I'd like to think if I
dropped a hundred subs,
I would want him to be like,
'yo, thanks for the hundred subs!'
Like, at least a tiny bit of recognition
from the person who I'm
subbing it to, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But its just like, he's
not gonna see this at all.
I'ma just drop 500 bucks just like that.
Just because I can.
Its like, I don't know,
I don't know what the mentality
of it is, because like,
I've given subs.
- I don't think anyone does at this point.
- Right. Because like, I've
gifted subs before on stream,
right, on like, other people's
Chats or whatever but like,
dropping a hundred subs on
a dude who's fucking asleep.
(Garnt laughing)
Its like,
what goes through your head to be like,
'yeah, I'ma do that.'
- I mean I think its
just being part of like,
this experience, right?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Because I feel like,
this is, you feel like,
the thing about Twitch that, you know,
I kind of understand is like,
you do feel like, you're
being a part of something
bigger than yourself, right?
(affirmative murmuring)
- Yeah, true.
- And I feel like, especially like,
obviously he didn't think
it would be this successful
that it was a fucking a genius move.
- [Joey] Yeah, absolutely.
- It was like, one day
in he made like, $150,000
or something. So even just like,
I know he he doesn't
seem like the kinda guy
who gives a fuck about the money.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Yeah Yeah.
- But I mean, but he's gonna. He's.
- But there's also a part
of me where its like,
I just threw away my
humanity for $150,000. Right?
- Its like, sign me the fuck up!
(all laughing)
- Are you kidding me?
(Garnt laughing)
- Film every part of my life for $150,000?
- Bro I will shit myself for $150,000.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I will poop myself
on stream for $100,000.
- Any billionaires wanna?
- Trash Taste shitting special, let's go.
- Any billionaires wanna fund this?
- The next Trash Taste livestream,
look out for one of us shit
farting live on Twitch.
(all laughing)
Jesus Christ.
- I just thought of like,
the most cursed content I can think of.
- [Joey] What?
- You just lock people in a room and just,
see who shits themselves first.
They can't go to the toilet.
- That's Mr Beast's next video.
- That's Mr Beast's video, right?
Last person to shit themselves
wins a million dollars.
(all laughing)
- Its like, survivor, just with shit.
- Jimmy I just gave you
a fantastic idea, bro.
You don't have to give me credit for that.
- Oh. Oh my god. Where do we go from here?
- I don't know mate. I don't know.
I just find it fascinating
bro, its like, you know,
you see a content creator
like Ludwig on Twitch
where he's just fucking doing something
that is not exactly the most unique thing,
but its also that one
thing where its like,
well I wouldn't fucking do it so obviously
no one's gonna do it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Right. But I'm just like, when it gets
to this point of like,
yeah I've been streaming
for two weeks straight like,
can it go up from there?
Like, what is gonna be the next thing?
- Everyone's gonna be waiting
for the next subathon.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And I'm just like, god no.
- And its just gonna
be even longer, right?
- Yeah.
- No, please no.
- And like, that's like, I don't think
there'll be a subathon
that'll be as popular as this
because he was the first one who did it.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Unless he does it again.
- I mean, even if he does
it again I feel like,
the hype wouldn't be as big
because, unless, I don't know.
- Unless it prematurely fizzles out,
where its like, oh what.
- I don't even know when
this one's gonna end yet.
- Right.
- So who the fuck knows?
I mean its kinda like,
do you remember Twitch Plays Pokemon?
- Oh yeah, yeah. I was
actually about to say right,
the last time I saw this phenomenon
was during Twitch Plays Pokemon.
- Yeah that's the kind of shit
I'm gonna be telling my kids about.
- [Joey] Right.
- Like, honestly, I enjoyed the
Twitch Plays Pokemon
experience so fucking much.
- 'Hey son, remember that time
when Twitch Played Pokemon?
(Garnt laughing)
'No, Dad.'
- But its like, the Ludwig
thing is like, its like,
Twitch Plays Pokemon, but
instead of an algorithm
that's just reading the Chat,
its literally just a dude
reading everything in the Chat
being like, 'okay left, down, up, A'
- So, to explain Twitch
Plays Pokemon, like,
this was how many years ago now?
- Five.
- Oh god, like, five or six years ago?
- Five or six years ago, where
someone made, like, someone,
- It was an Australian dude,
- Was it an Australian dude?
- Yeah.
- So, basically someone made a program
that would allow the Twitch Chat to play
a full game of Pokemon, right?
So I think it was Pokemon Red?
- Yeah it was the first gen Pokemon, yeah.
- That was played.
- [Garnt] And basically, the
Chat could put in their inputs,
- [Connor] For fun.
- [Garnt] Yeah, and
whatever inputs were put in
would be inputted into this emulator
that would be played
live in front of like...
- Yeah so if you typed in 'left' in Chat,
and entered it, then the program
would, in order, go left,
but the trick is, there
was literally what, like,
50,000, 100,000 plus people.
- Yeah, watching this stream.
- Watching and Chatting.
- And Chatting, like, at the same time.
- Its like giving the Game
Boy to 100,000 people at once.
And being like, finish this game.
- Yeah. And its one of the few times
where the word 'social experiment'
actually meant 'social experiment', right?
(Joey laughing)
- Dude, it reminds me of,
I saw a clip the other day and it was like
'if the moon landing
happened with Twitch Chat'
and then they were like literally
just put like, an overlay,
and it was like, 'Pog! Pog, its landing!'
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Its such a good video.
I imagine how much more hype
would the moon landing be
with a bunch of pogs and shit.
- Oh. Dude. I absolutely
would be pogging the Chat.
(Screen warping)
- This video is sponsored by Liquid I.V.
- [Joey] When you push your body hard,
or just feel run down,
its extremely important to stay hydrated.
Making hydration a priority
helps us feel healthier
on a day-to-day basis.
With one stick of Liquid
I.V. in 16oz of water,
you get two to three times
the amount of hydration
as plain water.
- Honestly? Every time I'm hungover now,
I take one of these bad boys.
I honestly feel a lot better.
- Well yeah, its like, doing
like, water times three. Right?
- Its just like.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It does help, actually. Memes aside.
Wait. What flavours do we have, Garnt?
- Well, today with us
we have lemon and lime,
and strawberry.
Which, this one, on
hangovers, they taste amazing,
they get you hydrated,
this is what you need.
- Liquid I.V. is so effective because
of their cellular transport technology.
I am not qualified to
know what that means,
but I feel very refreshed and
hydrated after I have a stick.
- So you can grab your Liquid
I.V. in bulk nationwide
at Costco, or you can get
25% off when you go to
LiquidIV.com and use code
TrashTaste at checkout.
That's 25% off anything you order
when you get better hydration today
using promo code
TrashTaste at LiquidIV.com.
- Remember bros, keep yourself hydrated.
Back to the episode.
(screen warping)
I would love to see sporting
events with Twitch Chat,
like, can you imagine how fun
the Olympics would have been?
If it was streamed on Twitch?
- Well its funny you say that because
I recently, someone in my
Twitch Chat notified me
of this Twitch channel that
streams the sumo on Twitch.
(affirmative murmuring)
- [Garnt] Okay.
- Dead ass there are people,
every time one of them wins,
there is dead ass just a stream of 'pog'.
(Garnt laughing)
and I'm just like, this is weird,
that people are pogging a sumo wrestler.
- There'll be like,
fucking professional
back seaters coming out,
like, you know, I'm sumo wrestled a...
(Garnt laughing)
- You know, this technique's
pretty fucking lacklustre.
(Garnt laughing)
- Here's how I would have
optimised that match.
(Joey laughing)
- Honestly this is just sloppy behaviour.
Dude, I saw a clip that popped
up on my YouTube as well,
and it was like, Twitch Chat
goes crazy about car stopping.
- [Joey] What?
- What?
- And it was just, like,
a camera that's watching
a street with a stop sign?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And.
- Like, a security camera footage?
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And
they're just streaming it.
And you can see Twitch Chat in the corner
and no one stops at the stop sign,
but then one car stops at the stop sign,
and Twitch Chat goes fucking crazy.
(Joey laughing)
and I'm just like, 'who's watching this?'
Why is there hundreds
of people watching this?
Going crazy?
- That's really funny.
- I feel like, its the equivalent of,
do you remember the DVD logo, on like,
(Joey laughing)
the DVD screensaver, and it
like, hitting the corner.
Actually is there a stream of that?
- There probably will be.
- I bet there would be a stream.
- I guaran-fucking-tee
there is a stream for that.
(Garnt laughing)
- Because I can imagine when
the DVD thing hits the corner.
Twitch Chat,
- Pog!
- The amount of pogs in chat, man,
the amount of pogs in chat.
- Every time its so close
its like, ah MonkaS.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- But no like, yeah, going
back to Twitch Plays Pokemon,
like, part of the amazing
experience of that was
being like, being part
of something bigger,
(affirmative murmuring)
and I just loved the lore that came out of
Twitch Plays Pokemon, right?
- What law?
- You weren't on the subreddit
and everything like that?
- I wasn't on the subreddit.
- Okay, so.
- Its like, factions forming
against each other, you know,
- Really?
- And stuff like that, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah. So you know,
what happened is, you know,
it was a random game
played by Twitch Chat,
or not random, but it was like,
it was like, a game
played by a lot of people
and a lot of random things happened,
and out of this randomness, like,
the community just created
a kind of storyline,
they created a narrative
out of the chaos that
was happening, right?
- Of course they did.
- And so, we're going full circle now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because an entire lore was created
out of the chaos and the randomness
that was happening on
Twitch Plays Pokemon,
- Right.
- Right. And so like, people
got invested in this narrative,
people got super, super
fucking invested in this lore.
- My god!
- The helix fossil.
- And the helix fossil, right?
- Oh, I mean yeah, I
know that's where like,
the whole like, Lord Helix meme came from.
(affirmative murmuring)
but like, that's the extent I know of.
- And then there's like, you know,
just, they wanted more.
Some people, like, a half
the people wanted more order,
and half the people wanted the chaos.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And there was just
like, arguing and stuff,
and it was quite interesting.
- Yeah, the only thing I remember
from Twitch Plays Pokemon
is, or, they eventually finished it,
I think they released
their starter within like,
the first like, hour or something?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I think people were
trying to sabotage...
- Yeah. People were trying to sabotage...
- Because obviously they were, yeah.
- And obviously then the
whole Lord Helix thing.
But other than that like, I don't know,
you know, at first when I heard about it,
oh I have to fucking go onto this,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And participate and somewhere I'm like,
I gotta be part of this history.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- The moment I went in
and the chat is moving so fucking fast,
where it just like, looks like a blur.
- [Connor] Yeah, I
remember I typed into...
- I'm like, nevermind, I'm good!
- I typed in a command and I was like,
well, I didn't see it.
- Yeah, exactly! I was trying
to catch it being like,
well I didn't see it. Fuck it, whatever.
- No because like, I mean
there was like, so many
epic moments created out of
the most mundane situations.
Like, I remember there was
this one ledge that took like,
fucking, eight hours to cross.
- [Connor] No, I remember this, yeah.
- [Garnt] And it was like, the
most epic ledge of all time.
I think I watched that collectively, like,
three hours at least, of my own time.
(Joey laughing)
And you know, we talk about
'what is the mentality of people
watching someone sleeping'
and I'm just like, wait a minute,
I just watched three hours
of this video game character
trying to cross a fucking ledge.
I have, I can't act like
I'm better than anyone else,
because I fucking did that as well.
- [Joey] Oh my god.
- We need like, a category
of competitive gaming
where its like, a team does
like, everyone gets one button,
on the game.
- [Joey] Oh my god.
- Like, Dark Souls but
everyone gets one button each.
- Well actually one of
my friends, they're like,
a couple streamer and they
do split control Sekiro?
- [Garnt] Oh.
(affirmative murmuring)
- So like, one of them is on the mouse
and the other is on the keyboard
and they beat the whole
game on split controls,
and I'm just like, this is
the type of shit that's like,
why. Why would you subject
yourself to this pain.
I can barely play Sekiro
with both of my own hands.
(affirmative murmuring)
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- Let alone having the fucking,
and also like, they manage
to beat the whole game
without getting mad at
one another? I'm like,
that's not how it works.
- Scripted!
- Yeah, scripted! Fake.
- What's wrong with you two?!
- What's wrong with you two?
- Have you seen that one
Twitch streamer who like,
plays League of Legends
with the most random inputs?
- Is it RossBoomsocks?
- I don't, I don't remember but.
- It might be like, bananas?
- Yeah, like, he played...
- What?
- He played League of
Legends using bananas.
(Joey laughing)
As inputs.
- What?
- Yeah. Because I think
its not that difficult,
because you just need something that,
because there's only really
like, four major buttons.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- So you just need to have
something that takes four inputs,
and you can literally
do that with anything.
- [Joey] Right. Right. Right.
- No I mean, that's why I think
I've been watching more
stream content right now,
because I think to me as a
YouTube creator, you know,
we watch a lot of YouTube and I feel like,
we can definitely see the formula
of good content on YouTube
and its rare nowadays that,
I look at a YouTube video
and I'm like, 'wow, that is,
you're doing something
really original right now,'
because I mean, you know,
we had a few years go
where Mr Beast completely
revolutionized the platform,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- and now it just feels like,
he's the one coming up with
the original ideas, you know,
Mr Beast, like, head and
shoulders about the rest.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I feel like, he's someone who is,
one, is someone who
understood the platform.
And two, now has the resources
to do the craziest ideas
that literally no one else
can even think of doing.
- No one else can do. Yeah.
- True.
- Like, who the fuck just
makes a fucking burger chain?
For content? Right?
(Garnt laughing)
Like, who else can do that?
- Well.
- Who else can do that?
- Dead ass, when I saw
that video in my sub feed,
I was like, 'its a wrap, guys,' like,
he just won the game.
- Yeah.
- Its kinda crazy.
- Yeah. Like, you know, there's, you know,
not to say there's people not
doing good content on YouTube,
but the amount of original
ideas you can put on YouTube,
(affirmative murmuring)
I feel like, there's
a lot less now because
one, someone with bigger
resources and is like,
probably smarter than
you is probably doing it?
And two, I feel like,
a lot of the original content
I see is now on Twitch.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I don't know if that's just because
I'm not being recommended
the right videos on YouTube?
- Yeah. No I definitely do just think that
right now we're kinda being like,
a golden age of like, Twitch creativity.
Like, there is just so many
ideas that people thought
would be like, either too much
effort or wouldn't, you know,
reap the benefits of doing it live.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Because there was just,
so much room for error.
But now, people have gone to the point,
and there's enough people,
I feel, now, on Twitch,
there's at least one
person who's gonna be like,
'this might be risky, for
a lot of different reasons,
but I'ma just try it,
and see if it lands.'
And a lot of the times,
it does land in ways that
no one was really expecting.
I mean like, 'oh, you
can do that on Twitch?'
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it be really fucking
successful, well then,
I'm gonna try and do it too.
And its just like,
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I don't know, I feel its just, like,
feeding the creativity to
more and more streamers
being like, oh,
I feel like, we're past the point of just,
get in front of a camera and
just start playing a game.
- Yeah.
- We're way past that.
- I don't know if you were ever like,
watching Twitch, and this
is the thing though, like,
marbles was like, a
huge thing at one point?
- Marbles?
- [Joey] What?
- Yeah. Like, watching a bunch
of marbles go down a course,
and like, seeing which one won.
- Like, Rude Goldberg machines, or like?
- No, just like, it was
like, there was like,
simulations of of like, marbles.
(Garnt laughing)
And people would like, bet on the marbles.
Like, I think Ludwig did this as well.
- Oh I think Tectone did it as well.
- Yeah, its just you
can assign things like,
the balls and just like,
let all these balls go down.
- Yeah.
- Whichever one wins you like, you know.
- Like, kinda like, Salty Bets?
- I don't know what that is.
- Salty Bets is, I'm not
100% sure about this, but
I believe someone made a
like, a program, right?
(affirmative murmuring)
where its, they pitted two
characters against each other,
in a fighting game.
- No.
- I'm not sure what the fighting game was,
- I know what you're talking about
- Yeah.
- They had like, fucking
Sonic going against like,
Chun-Li or something.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- I know what you're on about.
- Yeah.
- No. Its not.
- And people would be
betting on the winner,
even though it was completely,
you know, AI battle.
- [Joey] Right.
- No, its just like, the streamer,
I can't remember exactly
because I never watched it fully
because its really confusing.
- [Joey] I think its like...
- They were like, reacting to like,
these marbles, these virtual
like, games going down?
It was really bizarre.
- Its like, horse race
betting, but like, weirder.
- I find that like, stuff
like that does well on Twitch
when you're overreacting to dumb shit.
- Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- Well that's the whole
reason why at one point,
or I mean, I would
argue, still to this day,
people love watching people
do Gacha on stream, right?
Because its like, people losing their shit
to PNGs. Its like, well of
course I'm gonna watch this.
This is ridiculous.
(Joey laughing)
- I'ma watch it and play
a part of it as well.
- I can say that because
I've done Gacha on stream.
And I have overreacted, and
its been fucking amazing.
- Oh my god! I got something out of there.
- I got a waifu! You know, its like,
its the same philosophy, right?
- Right, like, its just a
PNG, bro, its just a PNG.
- Its a PNG man, but then,
the amount of pogs I'm
seeing in the chat is like,
saying otherwise!
(Garnt laughing)
- No because yeah, I guess to me,
the one thing you can get
away, you can do on Twitch
or live streaming that you
can't do with YouTube content
is you just really have this
community aspect, right?
(affirmative murmuring)
And its something that, I
feel is getting more and more
like, before it was seen as like,
YouTube comments are just
the thing that comes after
the content, its the
reaction to the content.
- [Joey] Yeah.
But now like, the comments itself
and the reaction to the
content that's being made
is also part of the content itself.
(affirmative murmuring)
And that's what I see
being like, kind of like,
the future of online content
and how its kind of evolving right now.
At least that is, that's how I see it.
- [Joey] Right. Right.
- Because there's like, even with like,
Twitch streams that have
been put on YouTube,
you know, I feel like,
half the fun is lost
if they don't have the Twitch
Chat on the content itself.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because you miss a lot
of the context itself,
and if its just like, a stream highlights,
without the Twitch Chat
itself, I feel like,
you're missing half of the content itself.
- No I absolutely agree like,
I feel a lot of it gets
taken out of context,
where like, if you don't see the reaction,
it doesn't seem as
epic? As it actually is.
Like, its still epic,
but when you see a
Twitch Chat on the screen
going fucking crazy you're
like, oh this is really epic!
- Okay, this is an epic
gamer moment right now.
- I don't know if its
just placebo or whatever,
but its like, the moment
you see a hype Twitch Chat,
suddenly you're like, well I
have to get hype too, fuck!
- Yeah. Because when
you're watching on mobile,
who the fuck has the
chat open on the side,
because it like, squishes down the Twitch.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Its like, I'm not gonna
fucking watch this shit
with the chat box here.
- Its like, put it, just,
put it on the stream,
and then that way its the
best viewing experience
as well, yeah.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Yeah I mean like, I don't
watch Twitch on the phone
most of the time.
- I mean, you know,
sometimes I wanna watch
Twitch and I'm like,
- Ill watch it every now and then
like, oh if I'm on the
train somewhere, you know,
like, oh someone's streaming or whatever.
- You know, I guess, do you
guys watch a lot of like,
Twitch and live streaming itself
or do you watch the highlights?
- I mostly just like, jump
into one of my friends streams,
if they're streaming, just say hi.
- Right.
- Yeah, normally I watch
my mates streaming,
ah so what are you up to, huh?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Its just kinda like...
- I literally use it as an excuse
to just catch up with my friends.
(Garnt laughing)
Its like, I could like,
message you on Twitter
DMs or whatever, but like,
you're here right now,
you're gonna respond to me.
- I do watch highlights too,
just not as often? I prefer,
I still prefer a normal
YouTube videos on YouTube.
- Right. Right. Right.
- Yeah, I don't, there's
so much shit I gotta watch,
like, anime, and I love watching anime.
- Anime? What is that?
- I know right? I don't know her.
But yeah, yeah I wanna keep
doing all the things I like.
- Yeah.
- So its difficult to keep up everything.
- Yeah, its kind of like,
there's just so much content
that I wanna watch now
and there's not enough time anymore. Like.
- Yeah, tell me about it.
- Literally can't get more
first world problem than that.
(Joey laughing)
- There's just too much to do!
- There's just too much content.
- What am I supposed to do?
- There's too much
content, man. Life sucks.
In a good way.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- In a good way, yeah. Exactly.
- But I mean like, okay.
Here's a question for you guys.
Do you like, when you
watch YouTube and Twitch
do you feel like its part
of your job to watch it?
- Nah.
- Or do you,
- No. No. I don't. I still
feel like I'm, you know,
back in 2013 watching my
favorite content creators.
- Right.
The only change is now is that,
you know, oh shit they follow
me, maybe, on Twitter. Maybe.
They probably don't. But maybe.
- I don't know, like, in a
way, to me, it kind of is.
Its like half half for
me, because its like,
(affirmative murmuring)
you know, there are some
videos that just pop up
on my recommended where I'm just like,
this is so little to do
with what I do for a job
that it just becomes entertainment.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But then there are parts
of me which are like,
I could like, say, watch
a video idea, or a video
that has this particular idea
that I had no idea existed.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And there's, I'd be lying if I said
there wasn't a part of me that thinks
'oh I wonder if I can use
this idea this video's using,
and kinda spin it in a way
for my own content.' Right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Its like, its not so much like,
I'm going out onto YouTube
just trying to find the
next idea or whatever,
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But sometimes, there are some videos,
where its just like, 'I could do that?'
But in like, a kind of fun and
unique way for myself, right?
- Yeah, because I do that as
well where I watch YouTube,
I watch Twitch,
I'm constantly looking for
ways to improve my own content.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And seeing some things
that I can maybe like,
not one on one ripping
someone off, but like,
taking an aspect and being like,
'I can put my own spin on that,' right?
- Right, like, you know,
there have been moments
where I have made entire videos
based off ideas from like,
three or four completely unrelated videos.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And just kinda being
like, Ill take you know,
this idea from this video,
and this idea from this
completely separate video.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And what do you know?
I've come up with something
kinda cool and unique
that I can work off of as well.
Which is, kinda unique and
interesting to my audience.
- Yeah because like, I think there's like,
its really looked down upon?
(affirmative murmuring)
I don't know if its just
the creator community,
or even like, whenever
with an audience as well,
whenever you see something
that kinda resembles someone else,
you're just like, 'ah,
you're just ripping off X'.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Or 'you're just ripping
off Y,' whereas like,
I don't know, to me, like,
artists, like, musicians,
and like, you know, movie makers,
they're like, really open
about their influences.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Like, like.
- Some of them wear their
influences on their sleeves.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And people are just like, 'cool!'
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah and I don't know
why its looked down upon
in the YouTube space because
everyone's exactly the same.
Everyone's been influenced by someone else
(affirmative murmuring)
on the platform, and its really like,
the rarer thing is finding someone
who's completely fucking original.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah.
- And like, even to me,
some of the biggest content
creators where, in my minds,
they were just like,
they did something completely
original content like,
for example, NakeyJakey,
(affirmative murmuring)
where I feel like he's doing
something very, very different
from what other people are doing,
even he says 'oh yeah,
I'm kinda just like,
JonTron up on a green screen,' and...
- Yeah I think, yeah, I
think he's just saying
'I'm just a shittier JonTron
on an exercise bike.'
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- That's what he said in
a video, and I'm like,
I mean, you know, you obviously like,
its so obvious you were
influenced by JonTron,
but it doesn't matter because
you're putting your own
spin on it, in a unique way.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You're putting your own
personality on it, where now,
this supposed thing you ripped
off has just become you.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Joey] All right?
- I mean you know, I
don't really give a shit
if someone does one of my video ideas.
- Nah.
- You know, you can 100% just take it.
Yeah, if you're gonna 100% take the idea,
it would be nice to be like,
'ah I got this idea from this person.'
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah.
- Because if I blatantly copy a video,
I'll just be like, oh yeah...
- I mean like, who was that person
who just blatantly copied Mr
Beast for the longest time?
- [Joey and Connor] Morgz?
- That was it.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I mean like, on that
level, its so obvious
that its just kinda like,
kinda like a one to one copy.
- Copying thumbnail,
title is a little much,
because you might be
fucking with things there.
But like, taking the video
idea is like, whatever, I mean.
- Right, I mean, I've seen, you know,
a bunch of YouTubers who have
done videos that you know,
I have come up with, or I was known for.
(affirmative murmuring)
And I've been okay with it because they've
put their own spin on it,
where its just kind of become like,
well I know where you
got influence from, but.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- This has just become your video now,
so I'm fucking okay with it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- If it was like, one for one like,
ripping like, using the
same type of thumbnail,
using the same type of title,
and then the content
is almost one for one,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then you don't mention
the person you got it from,
then yeah, I'll be like,
well that's a little bit
shitty isn't it? Like.
(affirmative murmuring)
- Because like, one of like,
one of the biggest questions
I get asked is like,
how do I go about like, a
new content creator is like,
'how do I go about making content?
How do I go about making original ideas
and finding my own style?'
And like, I always say
'you know what, I don't see any problem
with just starting by copying
some of your favorite creators,' right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because you will find your own style,
the more you do your own content, right?
(affirmative murmuring)
but its not something
that you immediately like,
its not something that you
immediately figure out.
And even like, some people do,
but those are the rare, rare people.
- Yeah, those are like,
the true geniuses, right?
Its like, not everyone
on YouTube is a genius.
- Yeah and I think it should be fine
for creators in our field just to like,
wear their influences on their sleeves
and just be open about it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, not completely copying, but like,
every like, every, you know.
Everyone has their influences
and everyone continues to
evolve from different people
they see on the platform.
At least that's how it is with me.
I think it should be fine, you know?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think everyone's being
influenced by each other.
- Yeah, because everyone, you know,
I don't know a single YouTuber
who doesn't watch YouTube.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Like, I mean, that's
the reason why we're here.
- Yeah. I mean, you know, like,
I always get reminded of that
Picasso quote which is like,
"good artists copy, great
artists steal." All right?
(Garnt laughing)
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And like, a lot of people, like,
kind of take that quote
completely out of context.
Thinking like, well then I'll
just fucking steal things.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I actually read up on why he said that,
and what he meant by that,
which is a great artist
steals in the sense that
they take an influence and
they turn it into something of their own.
(affirmative murmuring)
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- And I feel that's very
valid to any creative field,
whether that be an artist,
or a movie producer or a YouTuber,
where its like, you can get
influenced by other people,
but its, you have to do
it to the point where,
you put your own thing on it
where it becomes your own thing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- All right? And that's really hard to do,
and you know, great artists
steal, good artists copy,
you know.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- YouTubers who just copy an idea,
but don't do anything creative with it
are the ones that are just like,
well you're a fucking copycat aren't you.
(affirmative murmuring)
- I think that oh, did
you wanna say something?
- I never really thought about
it much, I was just like.
(all laughing)
I just watched YouTube and make my videos.
- We're getting awfully
philosophical about it.
- Here we are, I'm just sitting in my,
I make fucking stupid videos.
That's kinda how I view it.
I'm just like, all right,
ill keep uploading the same shit.
- I mean, yeah, I'm like
that too, but you know,
I'd be lying if I said there
wasn't a part of me that,
did think about that. Like, oh god.
I mean, this is a cool idea,
and I want to, you know,
incorporate it and do it
because it just seems like
something fun to do, but.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know. I sometimes
get worried being like,
are people gonna come out and be like,
'how dare you steal this
X and X's idea,' right?
- I think about stuff like that
and then I just also remember like,
some of the most popular videos are like,
pee pee poo poo stinky, and like,
that sharting sound effect so like.
The moment I try and
get all deep about it,
I'm like, 'I don't think its that deep,'
I think its just people,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
uploading stuff that makes them hehe XD.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- I don't fucking know.
- I mean I do think you register it.
- Subconsciously, yeah. I definitely do.
- Because I feel like,
you know, when people ask
'how do you like, what does it take
to become a successful
YouTuber,' a lot of things that,
the one thing that a lot of
people don't mention is that
step one, I feel like, is
to watch a lot of YouTube.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Well, yeah. Of course, like.
- No. Because I mean, you say of course,
but I know people who don't
watch too much YouTubers,
or if I'm just like, name
ten to twenty YouTubers.
- Oh like, they see YouTube on the news,
and they're like, 'I wanna be a YouTuber.'
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- And I feel like, not a
lot of people talk about,
a lot of YouTubers I know,
they watch a fuck ton of YouTube, right?
And it feels like,
there are so many subtle things
that you can't really explain to someone
unless they just understand the platform
because they watch a fuck-ton of YouTube.
- And its not just watching
a fuck-ton of YouTube,
its watching a fuck-ton
of different YouTube.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- Its like, I could be
like, name ten, you know,
YouTubers and if all of them
are the same type of content,
then its like, well, you
understand that type of content,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But everything else is
just a complete blank to you, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- You're probably not gonna go very far
because you're just, gonna be recycling
the same content from
those ten YouTubers, but.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Or its just like, watching
YouTubers who were popular
like, five years ago.
- [Joey] Right.
- I still watch Ray
William Johnson every day.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I strive to be my own
equals three one day.
- My day doesn't begin
without the Ray William.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- And yeah, I just think you know,
the idea of like, yes I would
like to become a YouTuber
because they are successful
now, and you know.
- And they make lots of
money for an easy job, right?
- Yeah. Yeah. And I feel like,
step one for even consider
becoming a YouTuber
or a streamer, is just to
watch a fuck ton of things
on that platform.
- No, no. Step one is
delete your Twitter history.
You've probably got some bad shit.
- You don't wanna get cancelled for that.
- Should probably, should
probably get rid of that.
- Then step two is watching.
- Privatise your Facebook,
delete your Twitter history.
- Yeah, because I mean
that's how I feel about like,
Instagram and TikTok, because
I don't use those platforms,
and I'm not gonna try to grow
on those platforms because.
- Because you don't use it, right?
- Because the first step
is I don't understand it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So its kinda like, to me, its just like,
the 'hello fellow
Instagrammers' kinda thing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- If I try to like.
- You just turn into one of
those corporate brands, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Its like, 'yes, we understand you.'
- Here's more picture of my food,
that's what you all like, right?
(Garnt laughing)
- Why aren't you liking it?
- But yeah, I mean is there anything else
you guys wanna talk about?
- I don't know man, YouTube can be deep
but it can also be poo poo pee pee stinky.
I think that's what I've
gotten out of today's episode.
- What I've gotten out of
today's episode is that
I don't understand
streaming content sometimes,
and that's why I watch it.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, exactly, right?
Like, you know, I feel
a lot of the reasons why
people watch a lot of
YouTube and you know,
Twitch streaming and stuff
like that for you know,
people who want to get into it is
because they want to understand it, right?
They want to grow a greater
appreciation towards it.
I mean, that's why I watch it.
- Just fucking fascinates me, man.
- Oh dude.
- Twitch, Twitch is fascinating to me now.
And that's why its probably
the content that I'm
watching the most right now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know, until
I understand it fully,
I'm gonna keep watching it, I guess.
- You get addicted, Garnt,
to everything that you do.
- I, that's.
- Yeah, you do tend to be like,
I like this one thing now,
I'm gonna like it 'til the end of time!
- Garnt will just come back and be like,
guys you won't believe it.
I've just discovered this
thing called mahjong.
And me and the boys at r slash mahjong
have been talking about
all the different strats,
and been watching...
- I'm in this photo and I don't like it.
(all laughing)
- I've watched the movies with the boys,
and its like, all right, calm down.
And Garnt forgets about
mahjong the week next.
- Yeah, he's like...
- That's pretty much me.
Like, I'm the kinda guy
who finds it really easy
just to fall into this
one random rabbit hole,
(affirmative murmuring)
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then I reach the
bottom of that rabbit hole
and I'm just like, okay.
Time to find something new.
- Time to claw out of this one.
- Literally the Toy Story meme of like,
'I'm done with you.'
- Yeah.
- I don't wanna play with you anymore.
I don't know, yeah.
That's me in a nutshell,
and the thing is, I'm
so easily influenced.
All it takes is just one
random YouTube recommendation,
or one thing popping up
on my Twitter to be like,
I find this thing, this
piques my curiosity.
Let me look into this, and like,
a week later, I'm just like, guys,
I have just consumed a
week's worth of content
on horseriding. Like.
(Connor laughing)
- Your thing right now
is fucking Chug Jug.
(Garnt laughing)
That's what that shit
is. And I'm just like,
- Dude, dude.
- I'm just thinking to myself like,
I'll just let him talk
because by next week he'll be
talking about something else.
He'll be done with this
rather shallow rabbit hole.
- He'll get over it.
- Just see me in a week guys,
I've become a Fortnite gamer.
(Joey laughing)
I'm going to be a pro Fortnite gamer.
- We can be pro Fortnite...
- You know what I won't
get over? Our patrons.
- That's true, they're wonderful.
Like this guy right here.
- I absolutely love this guy.
This is a rabbit hole I
will never get out of.
- [Connor] Yeah. (Joey laughing)
- Please, feel free to fall down
the Trash Taste rabbit hole.
There is definitely a
Trash Taste rabbit hole.
- Oh, absolutely, and if
you wanna support the show,
make sure to go over to
Patreon.com/TrashTaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
Fall down the Trash Taste
rabbit hole on our subreddit,
and if you hate our faces
listen to us on Spotify.
- Yes. Lets see how deep we
can make this rabbit hole go.
- I just want this, the lore
on the Trash's subreddit
to just get absolutely
fucking out of control.
Where its like,
they're just throwing
in big YouTubers like,
doing shit now, its like,
'horse riding, the, Felix
said the word trash.
We have to add that to the lore.'
(all laughing)
Its got nothing to do with anything.
- Its true, it should be on the lore.
- Yeah, exactly.
- We always want to, we just want to like,
expand this universe as far as it will go.
I just want to get a the point
where the Trash Taste lore
competes with fake lore.
(Joey laughing)
- The Trash Taste cinematic universe.
(Garnt laughing)
- TTCU.
- Oh my god.
- Well, thank you. Thank you
for joining me today, Joey.
- [Joey] Yeah.
I'm gonna go sleep.
- Thank you for joining me, Connor.
- I've had like, three
hours of sleep today,
I'm ready to die.
- I feel like you're like that every week.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- No this week is an exception.
I was great and then the
last half hour I was like,
whoa, I'm tired.
- Yeah, I noticed, I
looked over and I'm like,
you gonna add to this
conversation, Connor?
You're just like.
- Sometimes I'm just like,
see if Connor wants to add
something, and he's just like,
'I am having trouble forming words right.
- Yeah it was the first hour
and a half today I'm like,
oh I feel Gucci then the last half hour,
it hit me like a ton of bricks.
- The last half hour you were just like,
AOL loading sign.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
- Anyways guys, hopefully you enjoyed,
and we'll see you guys next week.
- [All] Bye!
(relaxing music playing)